I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, everyone. Good morning, you guys.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作专属的终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。大家好。大家早上好。
It's early here today for us. It's early here. And we have a lot to cover. So much. We came in early. We have so much to say today, but I have to point out an observation before we get started. Is it all my snacks and beverages on my side? You actually do have a ton of snacks and beverages.
我们今天来得很早。我们今天来得很早。而且我们有很多内容要聊。内容太多了。我们来得很早。今天我们有太多话要讲了，但在开始之前，我必须指出一个观察结果。是不是我这边的所有零食和饮料？你确实带了一大堆零食和饮料。
You have a hot tea, a cold tea, a water, a granola bar, a banana, and some naughty oats cereal. I do. It's a lot. You knew this was going to be a big episode. I came ready. Clearly. I came ready.
你有一杯热茶、一杯冷茶、一瓶水、一根燕麦棒、一根香蕉，还有一些淘气燕麦片。我确实带了。这真不少。你知道这会是内容丰富的一集。我做好了准备。显然是的。我做好了准备。
You have an entire picnic. I came up with iced tea and snacks. Just know that. That's me rolling into any event. My observation was actually going to be about your document. It's so charming. It is printed words. It's not note cards.
你带了整整一场野餐。我带了冰茶和零食。要知道这一点。这就是我参加任何活动的风格。我其实是想观察你的文件。太有魅力了。那是打印出来的字。不是便签卡。
It is a pile of paper. But what you have done is you have taken like regular, lined, what's that paper called? It's called notebook paper out of a spiral binder. Because clearly I ran out of printer paper. Is that what happened? That's what happened. That's why your pages are on lined notebook. It's printed though.
那是一叠纸。但你做的事是，你拿了普通的、有横线的，那叫什么纸来着？那是从螺旋装订本上撕下来的笔记本纸。因为我显然用完打印纸了。是这样吗？就是这样。这就是为什么你的页数写在带横线的笔记本纸上。不过它是打印出来的。
Yes. Did you think that I just wanted to print on notebook paper? Lady, I didn't know what you were doing. You don't know. And I have a post-it note. I just found it interesting when we sat down. No, this is me, you know, last night as I print my document out, you might have heard a few expletives because we were out of printer paper.
是的。你以为我就是想在笔记本纸上打印吗？大姐，我哪知道你在搞什么。你根本不知道。而且我还有一张便签。我只是觉得当我们坐下来时，这很有趣。不，这是我，你知道的，昨晚我打印文件的时候，你可能听到了一些脏话，因为我们没有打印纸了。
So then I was like, damn it, it's nine o'clock at night. A good hack. There you go. Hack. Go into your kid's room, get their notebook, rip out the pages. Your printer will print on it. I feel like we might have helped some people today. We might have.
所以我当时就想，该死，晚上九点钟了。一个好妙招。给你。妙招。去你孩子的房间，拿他们的笔记本，撕下几页。你的打印机就能在上面打印。我觉得我们今天可能帮到了一些人。我们可能真的帮到了。
All right. Well, let's talk about why we're here today. It is Stress Relief Part 1, Season 5, Episode 14, written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by Jeff Blitz. Exactly. You might be thinking, ladies, it's Stress Relief. That isn't that big, except it had the cold open to end all cold opens. Oh, yeah.
好了。那么，我们来谈谈我们今天为什么会在这里。这就是《缓解压力（上）》，第5季第14集，由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧，杰夫·布里茨执导。没错。你可能会想，女士们，这是《缓解压力》。这没什么大不了的，除了它有一个空前绝后的开场白。哦，对。
Oh, yeah. We'll be breaking that down. Oh, yeah, we will. It's going to take a while. This episode originally aired as an hour-long episode. We're going to have to break it down in two parts. So today we're covering the first half of Stress Relief. Would you like a summary?
哦，对。我们会剖析那个片段。哦，对，我们会剖析的。这需要花点时间。这一集最初作为一小时长的剧集播出。我们得把它分成两部分来剖析。所以今天我们讨论的是《缓解压力》的前半部分。你想要一个总结吗？
I really would. All right. In the first parts with that cold open you were talking about, Angela, Dwight takes matters into his own hands when his coworkers fail to pay attention to his fire safety seminar. He used PowerPoint. Big mistake. Big mistake. He's going to give us a practical fire drill.
我真的很需要。好的。在前半部分中，正如你所说的那样，安吉拉，当同事们没有认真听他的消防安全讲座时，德怀特决定亲自采取行动。他使用了PPT。大错特错。大错特错。他要给我们上一堂实用的消防演习课。
Hands on. How will we react on our feet? That's right. Well, Stanley has a heart attack. It doesn't end well. It doesn't. And that lands Dwight in hot water with corporate. I mean, he almost burned the building.
亲自动手。我们会有什么临场反应？没错。好吧，斯坦利心脏病发作了。结果很不妙。确实不妙。这让德怀特陷入了公司的麻烦之中。我的意思是，他差点把大楼烧了。
Stanley had a heart attack. Dwight, how do you have a job? Michael hires a CPR expert to teach the office what we should do if Stanley has another heart attack. But Dwight has his own ideas of how to use the CPR dummy. Hello, Clarice. Oh, dear. Finally, we learned that Pam's mom and dad are having a rough patch in their marriage
斯坦利心脏病发作了。德怀特，你怎么还保住工作的？迈克尔雇了一个心肺复苏专家来教办公室的大家，如果斯坦利再次心脏病发作我们该怎么做。但德怀特对如何使用心肺复苏假人有自己的想法。你好，克莱丽丝。哦，天哪。最后，我们得知帕姆的父母在婚姻中遇到了瓶颈，
and that Pam's dad has actually been bunking with Jim and Pam. Sans robe. Yeah. Was he walking around in his tiny whiteies? I don't know. But she needs to get on my robe. Oh. Fast fact number one, this episode aired after the Super Bowl on Sunday, February 1, 2009.
而且帕姆的爸爸实际上一直借宿在吉姆和帕姆家里。没穿浴袍。是的。他是穿着他的小白内裤走来走去的吗？我不知道。但她得穿上我的浴袍。哦。趣味事实一，这一集是在超级碗播出后的周日，即2009年2月1日播出的。
I mean, if I had an air horn thing, I'd fire it off because this was huge for us. Sophia C wrote in to say, Jenna, I have a fast fact for you. Sophia. This was the most watched episode of the entire office series. What? Yeah. And she's right. I looked it up.
我的意思是，如果我有一个空气喇叭，我会把它按响，因为这对我们来说意义重大。索菲亚·C发信说，珍娜，我有一个趣味事实告诉你。索菲亚。这是整个《办公室》系列中收看人数最多的一集。什么？是的。她是对的。我查过了。
Angela, do you want to know how many people? Oh, my gosh. I'm horrible at guessing. Like you know, guess the jelly bean in the jar. I'm so off. I know. Yeah. I can't do that either.
安吉拉，你想知道有多少人吗？哦，天哪。我不擅长猜数字。就像你知道的，猜罐子里的果冻豆。我总是猜得离十万八千里。我知道。是的。我也做不到。
Okay. I'm going to guess 10 million people. That seems like a big number. That is a big number. But it was 22.9 million people. No way. Holy smokes. Yeah.
好吧。我猜有1000万人。这听起来是个大数字。这确实是个大数字。但那是2290万人。没门。天哪。是的。
So it is definitely the most watched episode of the office. And it's also the only episode of the office to ever reach over 20 million viewers. Wow. But now I have another question for you. I don't know. Is it more guessing number stuff? It's more guessing. No, Lord.
所以它绝对是《办公室》收看人数最多的一集。而且它也是《办公室》中唯一一集观众人数突破2000万的剧集。哇。但现在我有另一个问题要问你。我不知道。又是猜数字之类的吗？又是猜。不，老天。
It's not numbers, though. Oh, good. Well, I have a shot. That's what our second most watched episode was. Oh, no. Of the whole series? Of the whole series. This was number one.
不过不是数字。哦，太好了。好吧，我来猜一下。我们收视率第二高的是哪一集？哦，不。整个系列里？整个系列里。这是第一名。
What do you think number two was? The finale? The pilot. What? The pilot. Really? It had 11.2 million viewers. The pilot that I wore my own clothes in.
你觉得第二名是什么？大结局？试播集。什么？试播集。真的吗？它有1120万观众。我穿着自己的衣服拍的那集试播集。
Yeah. From Target. Wow. 11.2 million people saw your outfit. Well, you're welcome, America. Interestingly enough, airing after the Super Bowl did not seem to get us a bump in viewership going forward. Oh, it was like a one and done?
是的。从塔吉特买的。哇。1120万人看到了你的穿搭。好吧，不用谢，美国。有趣的是，在超级碗之后播出似乎并没有让我们的收视率在接下来有所提升。哦，就像是一锤子买卖吗？
Kind of. So the episode that aired before the Super Bowl was Prince Family Paper. And we had 8.7 million viewers. Okay. That was kind of our average range. After the Super Bowl is lecture circuit. And we actually had a drop in the ratings to 8.4. Oh.
差不多吧。所以超级碗之前播出的那一集是《王子家庭纸业》。我们有870万观众。好的。那差不多是我们的平均收视范围。超级碗之后是《演讲巡回路》。我们的收视率实际上下降到了8.4。哦。
So some regular viewers, I don't know. They were like, not after that Super Bowl stunt. Fast fact number two, Randy told me that there were rumors that we were going to get that 2009 Super Bowl slot from as early as the end of season four. Geez. Yeah. They planned that that far out. I guess so.
所以一些忠实观众，我不知道。他们大概觉得，经历过超级碗那个噱头后就不看了。趣味事实二，兰迪告诉我，早在第四季结束时，就有传言说我们要获得2009年超级碗的黄金档期了。天哪。是的。他们那么早就计划好了。我猜是的。
There had been some talk that maybe it would go to the apprentice. The apprentice was going to get the slot. But our executive producers really fought for the office to get it. And we did. Randy said it was part of our internal shooting records as of May 2008, which was well before we had ever started shooting season five. So we'd known for a while this was coming. I also reached out to Greg Daniels.
曾有传言说这个档期可能会给《学徒》。《学徒》将获得这个黄金档期。但我们的执行制片人极力争取让《办公室》得到它。我们真的做到了。兰迪说，这是我们截至2008年5月的内部拍摄记录的一部分，这远在我们开始拍摄第五季之前。所以我们早就知道这事要来了。我还联系了格雷格·丹尼尔斯。
Oh, yeah. What'd he have to say? He said this, oh, yeah. This was a big deal. Yeah. Quote, we threw our biggest guns at it, which is why Paul Lieberstein wrote it. That makes sense. It's a fantastic script.
哦，是的。他怎么说？他这么说，哦，是的。这可是件大事。是的。“引述：我们把最强火力都压上去了，这就是为什么保罗·利伯斯坦来写剧本。”这说得通。这是一个 fantastisch 的剧本。
I texted Paul yesterday just a few couplets of dialogue. I was like, this is perfection. I'll tell you what I texted him later. Well, Paul had been with us since the very beginning. He is one of our best. It made total sense that he should write this episode. Right. I got curious.
我昨天给保罗发短信，发了几行对白。我说，这简直是完美。我晚点再告诉你我给他发了什么。好吧，保罗从一开始就和我们在一起。他是我们最好的人选之一。由他来写这一集完全合情合理。没错。我很好奇。
Okay. I started doing a little digging. Angela, the script for this episode was 95 pages long. I know. I looked through it and I was like, what is this phone book I'm reading? Oh, my God. It's stress relief. The candy bag.
好的。我开始做一点深入了解。安吉拉，这一集的剧本长达95页。我知道。我翻阅了一下，当时我想，我读的这本电话簿是什么东西？哦，天哪。那是缓解压力。糖果袋。
Okay. The candy bag are alts, all of our alt dialogue. Yeah. All the extra jokes that they didn't put in the script that they want us to maybe shoot. Oh, my God. How long was it? Lady, it was 207 pages long. They had 207 pages of extra jokes.
好的。糖果袋里装的是备用对白，也就是我们所有的备用对白。是的。所有那些没有放进剧本里、但他们可能希望我们拍摄的额外笑话。哦，天哪。它有多长？大姐，它长达207页。他们准备了207页的额外笑话。
Yeah. On the ready to go. Yep. Oh, my God. So I thought we should tell everyone that this episode took us nine days to shoot. It was a very, very big deal. Greg also said that because we were running after the Super Bowl, it created a scrutiny from the network that was not normally present on our show.
是的。随时准备开拍。没错。哦，天哪。所以我觉得我们应该告诉大家，这一集我们花了整整九天时间才拍完。这是一件非常非常大的事。格雷格还说，因为我们是在超级碗之后播出，这引来了电视台的严密审视，这种审视在我们的节目中通常是不存在的。
Oh, yeah. Lots of notes, lots of opinions. Sure. Sure. This is a big piece of real estate. This will come up again later. Should I move us to FastFact number three? Yes.
哦，是的，有很多意见反馈，有很多不同的看法。确实，确实。这是一块黄金宝地。这在后面还会提到。我应该把大家带到趣味事实三吗？好的。
All right. FastFact number three, Greg told us that because there would be so many new eyes on this episode, new viewers, that they had to figure out a storyline that would appeal to both current office viewers and new ones. And they also had to find a way to kind of reintroduce everyone's characters so that new viewers could follow along. They really tried to stay away from existing storylines. So for example, there's no movement or mention of the Angela Andy Dwight love triangle.
好的。趣味事实三，格雷格告诉我们，因为会有那么多新目光关注这一集，会有新观众，所以他们必须想出一个既能吸引《办公室》现有观众又能吸引新观众的故事线。而且他们还必须找到一种方法来重新介绍每个角色的背景，以便新观众能够跟上剧情。他们尽量避开现有的故事线。所以举个例子，其中没有关于安吉拉、安迪和德怀特三角恋的推动或提及。
Right. There's nothing about the company is struggling and there might be layoffs. No, there's nothing very complicated. This is a very simple idea that can hook everybody. Yes. But they especially had to figure out how do we start this episode? How do we hook these new viewers and make them stay for the whole hour? Right.
没错。也没有关于公司经营困难、可能会有裁员的内容。没有，没有什么非常复杂的东西。这是一个非常简单的创意，能够吸引所有人。是的。但他们尤其需要搞清楚，我们该如何开始这一集？我们如何吸引这些新观众并让他们留下来看完这一整小时？没错。
So Greg had this idea. What if an office weirdo who wanted people to listen to his safety ideas actually caused a fire emergency? He was like, you don't have to know who's who. It has a lot of energy and a lot of physical comedy. There you go. I mean, that is brilliant. Greg is brilliant because instantly you're hooked.
所以格雷格有了这个主意。如果一个想要别人听取他的安全理念的办公室怪人真正引发了一场火灾紧急情况会怎么样？他说，你不需要知道谁是谁。这充满了活力和丰富的肢体喜剧。就是这样。我的意思是，这太绝了。格雷格太绝了，因为你瞬间就被吸引住了。
Everyone has an office like idiot that is going to like take matters in their own hands or something. I thought it was amazing. Well we will break down this epic cold open after the break, but I have one more thing to say. Okay. This is a bonus fast fact. Okay.
每个人身边都有那种办公室里的白痴，会把事情抓在自己手里或者做出类似的事。我觉得这太棒了。好吧，我们将在中场休息后剖析这个史诗般的开场白，但我还有一件事要说。好的。这是一个额外的趣味事实。好的。
Did you notice the main titles? Of course I did. Everybody is in them. I know. This is the first time that our main titles featured the entire cast. It was so cool. We were so excited. We all cheered when we watched it.
你注意到片头字幕了吗？我当然注意到了。每个人都在里面。我知道。这是我们的片头字幕第一次出现全体演员阵容。太酷了。我们太兴奋了。我们看的时候都欢呼了。
Oh my gosh. I remember my family too because like everyone in my family who had never seen the show saw it because it was after the Super Bowl and we were in the main titles. It was really exciting. It was special. It was special. The whole thing was special. I mean, there are all these little milestones along the way as we're doing this rewatch
哦，天哪。我也想起了我的家人，因为我家里所有从没看过这部剧的人都看到了，因为它是在超级碗之后播出的，而且我们在片头字幕里。这真的很令人兴奋。这很特别。这很特别。整件事都很特别。我的意思是，当我们重温这部剧时，这一路上有所有这些里程碑，
and as we're looking back at our journey, I'm realizing all of these firsts and I would have never imagined I'd be on a TV show that would run after the Super Bowl. Super Bowl is such a big deal. I remember commercial auditioning and everyone wanted like a Super Bowl commercial spot. If we could just, I still, I still am like, oh come on. Yeah. Let me throw a Dorito at your head and you catch it in your mouth and it ricochets off the ceiling, Super Bowl ad.
当我们回顾我们的旅程时，我意识到了所有这些“第一次”，我做梦也没想到我会参演一部在超级碗之后播出的电视剧。超级碗是如此重大的一件事。我记得去试镜商业广告，每个人都想要一个超级碗广告位。如果我们能，我依然，我依然会想，哦，拜托。是的。让我把多力多滋扔向你的头，你在嘴里接住它，然后它从天花板上反弹回来，这就是超级碗广告。
You heard it here Doritos. Office ladies throw Doritos and catch them. We'll do it. Jenna will do a cartwheel. Wait. She's very athletic. What? Oh.
多力多滋，你们听到了。办公室女士们扔多力多滋并接住它们。我们会这么做的。珍娜会做一个侧手翻。等等。她非常运动。什么？哦。
Better start working on my cartwheels. I guess so. Well ladies, should we take a break and then when we come back, everyone get ready. Buckle in because we have an epic cold open with an epic cold open breakdown. We do. It's going to be good. All right, you guys, let's get right to it. First of all, you should know we reached out to a ton of people to share with us how they
我最好开始练习我的侧手翻了。我猜是的。好了，女士们，我们是不是该休息一下，等我们回来，大家做好准备。系好安全带，因为我们将迎来一个史诗般的开场白以及对这个史诗级开场白的剖析。没错。这会很棒的。好了，伙计们，我们马上切入正题。首先，你们应该知道，我们联系了大量的人来和我们分享他们是
made this cold open happen. It was fascinating. It was. Actually finding out. So many different parts, right? We knew our part, right? But we're like, well, how did camera do it? How did they, like so many things.
如何拍出这个开场白的。这太迷人了。确实如此。实际上了解了这一点。有这么多不同的部分，对吧？我们知道我们自己的部分，对吧？但我们会想，摄像机组是怎么拍的？他们是怎么做到这一点的，有太多的事情。
How many things to capture? So Randy Cordray, you guys know, we love Randy. He told us they had several planning sessions, right? With all the department heads, we had our director, Jeff Blitz, cinematographer, Randall Einhorn. They had to walk through this whole dance that we did with the camera stunts, animal trainers, script supervisor, Vada, like tracking the continuity. And then our rock star, first AD, Kelly Cantley, she then broke it down into smaller moments.
有多少事情需要捕捉？所以兰迪·科德雷，你们知道的，我们爱兰迪。他告诉我们，他们开了好几次策划会议，对吧？与所有的部门主管，我们的导演杰夫·布里茨，摄影指导兰德尔·艾因霍恩。他们必须理清我们带着摄像机特技、动物驯导师、场记瓦达一起完成的整套动作，比如追踪连戏。然后我们的摇滚巨星、第一副导演凯莉·坎特利，她随后把它拆解成了更小的时刻。
In Holland, our editor who edited this sequence, he told me he was also brought in on those planning sessions. He said he got so much footage, but that it was actually really, really well organized and pretty easy to edit because they planned so well. Way to go guys. Randy told us that we spent an entire day shooting this one whole day. To be exact, it was Thursday, December 11th. Oh yeah.
我们的剪辑师霍兰德剪辑了这段序列，他告诉我他也参加了那些策划会议。他说他得到了大量的素材，但实际上组织得非常非常好，而且剪辑起来相当容易，因为他们计划得太周全了。干得好，伙计们。兰迪告诉我们，我们花了一整天的时间拍摄这整整一天。准确地说，那是12月11日，星期四。哦，是的。
And we had tons of safety meetings, all the safety stuff. I remember we did not shoot this in order, right? We shot it out of order and some of that was for safety reasons. Yeah. Let's describe it and then we'll go back and we will break it down piece by piece. All right. Here's your overview, everybody. Here's your overview of the cold open.
我们有大量的安全会议，所有的安全事项。我记得我们不是按顺序拍的，对吧？我们是打乱顺序拍的，其中一部分是为了安全原因。是的。我们来描述一下，然后我们再回过头来逐段剖析。好的。各位，这是你们的概览。这就是开场白的概览。
The first shot is Dwight opening his desk and he's sort of motions to the camera all sneaky and he's got lighter fluid and what looks like to be a blowtorch. Yeah. You know, something's up, something Dwight-ish. He goes in the hallway and he's kind of hiding out and he's whispering to camera and he starts like jamming the doors. He puts a key in, he hammers it shut, he puts his little wood wedges under and yeah, blowtorches the door handle and starts his speech.
第一个镜头是德怀特打开他的办公桌，他有点偷偷摸摸地向摄像机示意，他拿着打火机油和一个看起来像是喷灯的东西。是的。你知道，有情况要发生，一种德怀特式的阴谋。他走到走廊里，有点躲藏起来，对着摄像机耳语，然后他开始像是在破坏门。他插进一把钥匙，用锤子把它敲死，他在下面塞进他的小木楔子，然后，用喷灯烧门把手，开始他的演讲。
Yeah. He says that nobody paid attention to his fire safety seminar. He blames himself for using PowerPoint and that experiences the best teacher. So he will teach his co-workers proper fire emergency procedure the hard way. And you guys, today's cigarettes are going to save lives. Yeah. As he smokes cigarette and then tosses it into a trash can and immediately a fire starts. But no one notices it first.
是的。他说没有人关注他的消防安全研讨会。他怪自己用了PPT，而经验是最好的老师。所以他要用艰难的方式教导他的同事们正确的消防紧急程序。伙计们，今天的香烟将拯救生命。是的。当他抽着烟，然后把它扔进垃圾桶时，火立刻就烧起来了。但起初没有人注意到。
No one notices. There's smoke piling in under the door. And everybody's just quietly working and it's really frustrating Dwight. So he's like, do you guys smell something and Angela's so snarky as like, did you bring your jerky in today? I know. And then Pam notices it. But Jenna, Pam notices it the way I react in moments like this.
没有人注意到。浓烟从门底下滚滚涌入。每个人都在默默地工作，这让德怀特很沮丧。所以他问，你们有没有闻到什么味道，安吉拉尖酸刻薄地说，你今天带牛肉干来了吗？我知道。然后帕姆注意到了。但是珍娜，帕姆注意到它的方式就像我在这种时刻的反应一样。
You notice she didn't say fire. Yes. There's a, oh my, it's off. She freezes. Yeah. Michael starts yelling for everyone to stay effing calm. Dwight is kind of shouting proper safety procedures, but people are panicking. It's suddenly total chaos.
你注意到她没有喊“着火了”吗？是的。有一个，哦，天哪，它断了。她僵住了。是的。迈克尔开始大喊让大家保持他妈的冷静。德怀特在大声宣读正确的安全规程，但人们在恐慌。突然之间一片混乱。
This is what it sounded like. Oh my God. Okay. It's happening. Everybody stay calm. What's the procedure, everyone? What's the procedure? Stay f***ing calm.
听起来就是这样的。哦，天哪。好的。发生了。大家都保持冷静。程序是什么，大家？程序是什么？保持他妈的冷静。
Wait, wait, wait, wait. Everybody stay f***ing calm down. No. No, Michael. Exactly. Well, amid all the chaos, Angela gets a cat out of a file cabinet. Yeah. Oscar escapes up into the ceiling.
等等，等等，等等，等等。大家都他妈的冷静下来。不。不，迈克尔。没错。好吧，在一片混乱中，安吉拉从文件柜里抓出一只猫。是的。奥斯卡逃到了天花板上。
I know you're going to have a lot to tell us about that. Yeah. And then Michael smashes a window in the conference room. Kevin is going to make sure he's getting snacks during the fire. He's like busting up the vending machines. And then Dwight lights a bunch of firecrackers. Yep. To which Ed Helms as Andy says my favorite line in this cold open, which is, the fire
我知道你有很多关于这个的事情要告诉我们。是的。然后迈克尔砸碎了会议室的一窗玻璃。凯文要在火灾期间确保他有零食吃。他像是在砸烂自动售货机。然后德怀特点燃了一堆鞭炮。没错。对此，埃德·海尔姆斯饰演的安迪说出了我在这个开场白中最喜欢的一句台词，那就是，“火正在向我们开枪。”吉姆像是在把复印机撞向一扇门。最后，德怀特拉响了火警警报。为什么？因为斯坦利心脏病发作了。没错。是的。整件事太疯狂了。
is shooting at us. Jim is like ramming the copy machine into a door. Finally, Dwight pulls the fire alarm. Why? Because Stanley's having a heart attack. Exactly. Yes. The whole thing is insane.
是的。整件事太疯狂了。我们是怎么做到的？嗯，我们有一群非常棒的人，这就是我们是怎么做到的。我们和我们的摄影指导兰德尔·艾因霍恩谈过，了解他们究竟是如何捕捉到所有这些时刻的。我们联系了他。以下是他的言论。
Yeah. The whole thing is insane. How did we do it? Well, we had amazing people, that's how we did it. We spoke to our cinematographer Randall Einhorn about how exactly they captured all these moments. We reached out to him. Here's what he had to say.
是的。我和杰夫·布里茨、雷迪、凯莉·坎特利密切合作，你知道的，协调我们到底要如何拍摄那场戏，因为有太多的活动部件，太多的移动元素。它不希望感觉像是需要50台摄像机在拍摄。它总是希望感觉只有两台摄像机在拍摄，而且它们在艰难地拍摄。所以有很多事情需要解决，因为发生了太多事情。
Yeah. I worked really closely with Jeff Blitz and Ray D. Kelly Cantley to, you know, coordinate how exactly we're going to shoot that because there was a lot of moving parts, a lot of moving pieces. It didn't want to feel like it needed 50 cameras filming it. It always wants to feel like there's just two cameras filming it and they're struggling to film it. So it was a lot to work out because there was so much going on.
但因为我们能够在摄像机的横扫镜头上进行剪辑，我们能够把它们拼凑起来，让它看起来像是一个整体，因为当摄像机从一个东西摇到另一个东西时，如果你做对了，你可以让它看起来像是在一个镜头的结尾处创造一个剪辑点，然后摇到另一个镜头，另一个镜头的开头，这真的是它的制作方式。这就是我们如何把所有东西拼凑在一起，让它看起来像是一个疯狂的长镜头。通过这次重温，我学到了一点。我们多久使用一次这种甩镜头？
But because we're able to cut on some of the camera swishes, we're able to piece it together so it looked like it was one piece because as a camera's panning from one thing to another, if you're doing it right, you can make it look like you can create an edit point where you're panning from the end of one piece and you're panning into another, the beginning of another piece is really kind of how it's done. That's how we all pulled it all together and made it look like it was a one frantic take. I have learned doing this rewatch. How often we used that whip cut?
这是我们的老朋友。显然是的。这就是这个开场白诞生的原因。大姐，我们收到了大量关于这个开场白的粉丝提问，所以为什么我不把它们过一遍呢？好的。我们在本集开头说过，雷恩在锁门和放火方面搞了很多恶作剧。
It was our friend. Clearly. It's why this cold open happened. Lady, we got a ton of fan questions about this cold open, so why don't I go through them? Okay. We said at the top of the episode, Rain's doing all his mischief with the locking of the doors and setting the fire.
我们有一个来自杰登·C的粉丝提问：德怀特在那些门把手上使用的是真正的喷灯吗？看起来确实是。为什么我们不让雷恩·威尔逊来告诉我们呢？雷恩，你有什么要说的？是的。那是一个真正的活喷灯，不是CGI火焰。他们那里有很多安全官员，有一个消防队长和一个特效协调员，而且门把手实际上确实变得非常烫。
We had a fan question from Jaden C was Dwight using a real blowtorch on those handles. It certainly looked like it. Why don't we let Rainn Wilson tell us? Rainn, what you got to say? Yes. It was a real live blowtorch, it was not a CGI flame. They had a lot of safety officers there, a fire marshal is there and a special effects coordinator and the handles actually did get very hot.
现在他们可能会做CGI，甚至可能会用CGI让门把手变得有点红，但那完全都是真的。我不敢相信他们给了他一个真正的喷灯。如果你回顾一下他们在剧集中给雷恩的那些真正的东西。他们早该知道的，回到当他们给他那个会响的键盘的杰迪节（Dundies）。看看他对那个放屁键做了什么。不要给那家伙真东西。不要给那家伙真东西。
Nowadays they'd probably do CGI and maybe even make the door handle a little red with the CGI, but that was all completely real. I can't believe they gave them a real blowtorch. If you look back over the things they gave Rainn, that were real in episodes. They should have known going back to the dundies when they gave him that operating keyboard. Just what he did with the fart key. Don't give that guy real things. Don't give that guy real things.
好吧，是的，所以是真正的喷灯，还有什么？嗯，我们有另一个粉丝提问。人们想知道雷恩是不是真的在抽烟，罗希特·R想知道垃圾桶里的烟是不是真的，雷恩是这么说的。那是我抽并点燃的一支真正的香烟，我把它和纸一起扔进了垃圾桶里，但我认为他们在摄像机摇开的第二秒就跑过去扔了点水把它浇灭了，你在垃圾桶里看到的火是通过特效的魔力专家般地创造出来的。
Well, yeah, so real blowtorch, what else? Well we had another fan question. People wanted to know if Rainn was really smoking and Rohit R wanted to know if it was real smoke in the trash can, here's what Rainn had to say. It was an actual cigarette that I smoked and lit and I threw it in the garbage can with the paper, but I think they like ran in the second that camera panned away and tossed in some water and put it out and the fire that you see in the trash can is expertly created due to the magic of special effects.
整集中有那么多惊人的细节，保罗·利伯斯坦，我记得他指导我完成这些，我想是他写的，但保罗在很多细节上起到了非常重要的作用，比如我是怎么抽烟的，我是怎么随性地扔掉烟头的，他在脑海中大致勾勒出了楔子是如何被锤进门下的，还有所有的细节，我口袋里的锤子之类东西。所以伟大的保罗·利伯斯坦，也就是托比，在整部《办公室》中，特别是在这一集的开场白中，发挥了非常伟大的创作作用。哇，我不知道这一点。
There are so many amazing details throughout the episode that Paul Lieberstein, I remember guiding me through and I think he wrote it, but Paul was very instrumental in a lot of the details about how I smoked and how I casually tossed the cigarette and he had it kind of visualized in his mind how the wedges get hammered under the door and all the details, the hammer in my pocket and stuff like that. So the great Paul Lieberstein, aka Toby, really played a great creative part throughout the entirety of the office and especially in this episode in this cold open. Wow, I didn't know that.
我不知道保罗是所有这些节奏的幕后推手，所有的那些起火时刻的舞台调度。是的，我也不知道。另外，珍娜，顺便说一句，我从来没有在电影或电视节目中抽过烟，这会是一场灾难，因为我不知道怎么抽烟，而且会非常明显。我不会假装抽烟。好吧，对于我们所有的那些技术宅粉丝来说，兰迪为我详细剖析了他们究竟是如何在垃圾桶里制造那场火、那种烟的。
I didn't know Paul was behind all those beats, all the like staging of the fire moments. Yeah, me either. Also, Jenna, just on a side note, I've never had to smoke a cigarette in a movie or TV show and it would be a disaster because I don't know how to smoke a cigarette and it would be so clear. I wouldn't know how to be like fakey smokey. Well, for all of our like kind of techie nerds out there, Randy broke down for me exactly how they did make that fire in the trash can, that smoke.
所以雷恩是对的，对吧？他们扑灭了你看到的火。但为了制造那种滚滚的浓烟，那是特效团队在罗恩·内里的带领下制造的，对于烟雾，他使用的是一个水蒸气发生器，里面含有极微量浓度的乙二醇。我猜乙二醇是让水蒸气在空气中停留更长时间的原因。兰迪说它没有气味，并且得到了演员工会（SAG）和环球影城安全部门的批准，确认是安全的。
So Rain was right, right? They extinguished the fire that you saw. But then to create that smoke billowing in, that was created by a special effects team led by Ron Neri and for the smoke, he used a water vapor generator with a minute concentration of glycol. And I guess the glycol is what keeps the water vapor hanging in the air a bit longer. Randy said it had no odor and it was approved safe by both SAG and NBC Universal Safety Department.
什么是乙二醇？哦，不。谷歌一下？你可以谷歌一下？你可以谷歌一下？那是什么？是乙二醇吗？好吧，有两种乙二醇。
What is glycol? Oh, no. Google it? You can Google it? You can Google it? What is it? Is it glycol? Okay, there's two glycols.
哦。有一种是丙二醇。好的。然后有一种是乙二醇。嗯，其中一个是好人，另一个不是。好的。我猜，我想乙二醇是那种存在于防冻液里的东西，它有一种甜味。
Oh. There's propylene glycol. Okay. And then there's ethylene glycol. Well, there's one a good guy and one's not. Okay. I guess kind of, I think the ethylene glycol is the stuff that's in like antifreeze and it has like a sweet taste.
这就是它有毒的原因，对吧？你不会想让你的狗去舔它的。没错。人们总是在说不要舔你的防冻液。他们总是在说这个。对狗说。狗会想，我们听不懂你们在说什么。不，猫也喜欢它。
That's what it's poisonous, right? You don't want your dog to lick it. Right. They're always saying don't lick your antifreeze. They're always saying that. To dogs. The dogs are like, we don't understand you. No, cats love it too.
你得小心点。现在丙二醇是一种通常用作食品添加剂的物质。它存在于许多化妆品和卫生产品中，包括我想还有一些牙膏。哦。所以那是我们用的。我的意思是，我猜是的。嗯，我想其中一种乙二醇也可以用作某种纤维。我想我们没有时间来深入探讨乙二醇了，但我们很好奇。
You got to be careful. Now propylene glycol is a substance that's commonly used as a food additive. It's in a lot of cosmetic and hygiene products, including, I think, some toothpaste. Oh. So that's the one we used. I mean, I guess so. Well, I think one of the glycols can also be used as some sort of a fiber. I don't think we have time to end the moment, deep dive glycol, but we were curious.
所以我假设既然演员工会和环球影城说它是安全的，那么我们用的就是安全的那个。我们用的是安全的那个。看看我们。我们很好。我们在这。下一个粉丝提问来自迈基·S。当史密斯说“保持他妈的冷静”时，史蒂夫是即兴发挥的吗？没有。不过有点即兴。
So I'm assuming that since SAG and NBCUniversal said it was safe, then we used the safe one. We used the safe one. Look at us. We're fine. We're here. Next fan question is from Mikey S. Did Steve improvise when he said, stay effing calm? No. A little bit, though.
嗯，那是史蒂夫，对吧？我的意思是，他拿到了所有剧本，但有时他会在当下即兴润色一下。剧本上是这么写的。哦，天哪，发生了。让我过去。让我过去。保持冷静。保持冷静。
Well, that's Steve, right? I mean, he got everything scripted, but sometimes he would zhuzh in the moment. Here's what it said in the script. Oh, God, it's happening. Let me through. Let me through. Stay calm. Stay calm.
保持他妈的冷静。然后迈克尔暴力地挤到前面去。我想我们做到了。我的意思是，非常准确。我们还有更多的粉丝提问。安吉拉，杰登·C想知道迈克尔把投影仪扔进窗户扔了多少次？嗯，他先是用椅子，对吧？没错。
Stay effing calm. And then Michael violently pushes his way through to the front. I think we did it. I mean, very accurately. We have more fan questions. Angela, Jaden C. wants to know how many times did Michael throw the projector into the window? Well, he starts with the chair, right? That's right.
它没有碎。兰迪说，为此，我们用了一块有机玻璃。因为他们不想让它碎。他们希望他的第一次尝试不太顺利。是的。然后他们把有机玻璃换成了易碎玻璃，它非常逼真地粉碎了，但绝不会以一种尖锐或危险的方式粉碎。我有一个小趣味事实要告诉你。
It does not break. And Randy said that for that, we used a plane of plexiglass. Because they didn't want it to break. They wanted his first attempt not to go well. Yes. Then they replaced the plexiglass with breakaway glass, and it shatters very realistically, but it never shatters in a sharp or dangerous way. I have a little fun fact for you.
在好莱坞的旧时代，这被称为糖玻璃。我知道这个，珍娜，因为我和我爸去参观过一个老西部片场景，他们说，那些牛仔们被扔出酒吧和沙龙的所有窗户，都是糖做的。糖。你可以吃它。我猜现在它们不是用糖做的了，但兰迪说老派影人仍然称它为糖玻璃，尽管现在它被称为易碎玻璃。
In the olden days of Hollywood, this was known as candy glass. I know that, Jenna, because I got a tour of an old western set with my dad, and they were like, all those windows that guys get thrown out the bars in and the saloon, that was candy. Candy. You could eat it. I guess nowadays they don't make it out of candy, but Randy said old schoolers still call it candy glass, even though now it's called breakaway glass.
兰迪还告诉我们，杰登，为了回答你的问题，他们一次就拍成了。扔了一次投影仪就把易碎玻璃砸碎了。就是这样。杰登还想知道凯文砸了多少次自动售货机？我联系了布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳。他说他觉得大约拍了两到三条。他们用了那种相同的易碎玻璃。他说每次都碎了，但他们不得不额外多拍几次，只是为了把某种
And Randy also told us, Jayden, in answer to your question, they got it in one take. One throw of the projector broke the breakaway glass. There you go. Jayden would also like to know how many times did Kevin break the vending machine? I reached out to Brian Baumgartner. He said he thought it took about two to three takes. They used that same breakaway glass. He said it broke every time, but they had to do it a few extra times just to get a certain
摄像机运动拍对。你知道的，他们在做甩镜头。没错。为了让它看起来很疯狂。没错。接下来，大姐，我觉得我们应该讨论这个没有人留言询问、但却如此史诗般的时刻。我不敢相信没人留言问这个。
camera movement right. You know, they were doing the whip cuts. Right. To make it look frantic. Right. Now, next up, lady, I thought we should discuss this moment that no one wrote in about, but that was so epic. I can't believe no one wrote in about it.
我完全知道你在说哪个时刻，因为这对我们所有在片场的人来说都是一件大事。也许人们没有意识到这一点，因为克里斯·沃克曼是个多么了不起的硬汉。所以我们要谈论的是，在凯文的带领下，邓德米夫林的员工们跑过厨房并撞倒我们的摄像师兰德尔·艾因霍恩的那个时刻。伙计们，这完全是个失误。是的。我们当时想，哦，天哪，兰德尔倒了，但只持续了几秒钟。
I know exactly the moment you're talking about because it was such a big deal to all of us on set. And maybe people don't realize that because of what a badass Chris Workman is. So what we're talking about is the moment when, led by Kevin, the Dunder Mifflin employees are running through the kitchen and take down our camera operator, Randall Einhorn. Guys, this was a total mistake. Yeah. We were like, oh my God, Randall's down, but only for a few seconds.
我们联系了兰德尔，因为我们必须从他的角度听听这个故事。当布赖恩把他撞倒时。我记得当我倒着跑过休息室时，饰演凯文的布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳正向我跑来，因为他拼命想从那里逃出去。他一直追着我跑，追着我跑，离我越来越近，而我正拿着摄像机倒着跑，他离得太近了，我想他撞到了我，我摔倒了。我倒下了，但我的摄像师克里斯·沃克曼，一个非常强壮的家伙，只用了一只手臂就接住了我，
We reached out to Randall because we had to hear this story from his perspective. When Brian mowed him down. I remember when I was running backwards through the break room and Brian Baumgartner, who plays Kevin, was running at me because he's frantically trying to get out of there. And he just kept running on me, running and gaining on me and gaining on me and I'm running backwards with the camera and he just got so close that I think he hit me and I hit the ground. I went down, but my camera says Chris Workman, who's really strong guy, just caught me with
用一只手臂接住了我和摄像机，把我扶了起来。我大概有200磅重，摄像机将近40磅，而克里斯就这么把我举了起来。我甚至都不知道自己是不是摔倒了。但那个我摔倒又爬起来的镜头真的被剪进了正片里。所以感谢克里斯·沃克曼把我拉起来，也感谢布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳撞倒了我并拍出了这么酷的镜头。好吧，安吉拉，我觉得我们还需要听听布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳对这个时刻的看法。
one arm, caught me and the camera with one arm and put me back on my feet. And I'm like a 200 pound guy, the camera's nearly 40 pounds and Chris just lifted me up. I didn't even know if I hit the ground. But that shot of me going down and getting back up actually made the show. So thank you, Chris Workman, for picking me up and thank you, Brian Baumgartner, for running into me and making such a cool shot. Well, Angela, I felt like we also needed to hear from Brian Baumgartner about this moment
割草机和模式。没错。我们需要正反双方的观点。好吧，谢谢你，兰德尔。你知道的，我本来想取笑你把故事记错了，但你夸了我，而且把故事记对了一百。我的意思是，听着，我身后有人在跑，好吗？所以我必须跑过我面前的任何东西，否则我自己就会被撞倒。
the mower and the mode. Exactly. We needed a point counterpoint. Well, thank you, Randall. You know, I wanted to make fun of you for getting the story wrong, but you complimented me and got the story a hundred percent right. I mean, look, I had people running behind me, okay? So I had to run over whatever was in front of me or I would have gotten run over myself.
但仔细想想，这是有史以来第一次有人告诉我，我跑得比任何人都要快。我的意思是，你当时正扛着摄像机倒着跑。不过是的，我不得不把你放下。而且听着，我记得的事是，是的，据我回忆，你整个人是后背着地倒下去的。从我眼角的余光里，看起来就像是克里斯·沃克曼单手把你捞起来，把你扶回脚上，就像你一贯的专业作风一样，你只是继续拍摄。
But actually come to think of it, it's the first time that anyone has ever told me that I've outrun anyone. I mean, you were running backwards carrying a camera. But yeah, I had to put you down. And look, the thing I remember is, yes, you went all the way to your back, as I recall. And from me out of the corner of my eye, it looked like Chris Workman one hand picked you up, put you back on the feet and like the pro that you are, well, you just kept filming.
我很高兴它被剪进了正片。这是我最喜欢的剧集之一。它显然是在超级碗之后播出的。这对我也意义重大。是的，绝对是我们最搞笑的开场白之一。好吧，大姐，我清楚地记得那一刻，因为我确实记得兰德尔倒下了。我们该怎么办？然后兰德尔站起来了。
I'm so happy that it made it into the cut. And it's one of my favorite episodes. It aired after the Super Bowl, obviously. And that was a big deal for me. And yeah, one of our funniest cold opens, for sure. Well, lady, I just remember that moment so vividly because I do remember Randall is down. What do we do? And then Randall is up.
我想我们继续拍下去了。但这对我来说太神奇了。而且那是唯一发生的一次。那就是我们采用的那条。克里斯·沃克曼，天哪，他简直是个机器。好了，现在，我觉得我们需要讨论那件我们收到最多信件的事情。哦，是的。救救班迪特。
And I guess we continue. But it was amazing to me. And that's the only time it happened. And that's the take we used. Chris Workman, man, he is a machine. All right, now, I think we need to discuss the thing that we got the most mail about. Oh, yeah. Save Bandit.
救救班迪特！现在，“救救班迪特”是我们那天通告单上的最后一件事。我们其余的人都已经回家了。我知道他们这么做是因为这太复杂了。他们希望你们能独占片场。我当时不在。安吉拉，请告诉我们。你是怎么搞定这个的？
Save Bandit! Now, Save Bandit was the last thing on our call sheet for the day. All the rest of us had gone home. I know they did this because it was so complicated. They wanted you to have the set to yourself. I was not there. Angela, please tell us. How did you pull this off?
好吧，事情是这样的，伙计们。我们必须进行大量的排练。你们应该知道，在充满混乱、我们四处奔跑的那天，我在场。但猫在那些时刻没有工作，好吧？是的。猫确实和我们大家一起工作了一个时刻，珍娜，就是我打开抽屉然后你揭晓的那个。
OK, so here's the thing, guys. We had to have a lot of rehearsals. You should know on the day when there was a lot of the chaos and we were all running around, I was there. But the cat didn't work those moments, OK? Yeah. The cat did have to work one moment, Jenna, with all of us, where I opened the drawer and you reveal.
是的。那一刻你们所有人都在背景里。我实际上不得不把猫抱起来，走到我要把它扔掉的地方。仅此而已。这就是我和猫、以及现场的大家所要做的全部事情。珍娜，这只猫太巨大了。它看起来很大。我在想，你们是不是挑了他们能找到的最大的猫？
Yeah. You guys are all in the background for that moment. And I had to actually pick the cat up and walk over to where I would have tossed it. And that was it. That's all I had to do with the cat, with the group there. Jenna, this cat was massive. It looks big. I'm like, did you cast the biggest cat they had?
你是不是看到角落里那只最大的，然后说，我们要那只，伙计？在混乱中把它从抽屉里拿出来，甚至不对它做什么。只是把它抱起来，带到我的位置上。猫当时的想法是，哦，我要离开这儿。所以当真正拍摄特技部分时，我非常高兴你们所有人都已经离开了。没错。哦，天哪。猫要对付的活动变少了。
Did you see the big one in the corner and say, we want that, dude? Just taking it out of the drawer with the chaos, not even doing anything with it. Just picking it up and taking it to my spot. The cat was like, oh, I'm out of here. So I was really glad when we actually filmed the stunt part that you guys were all gone. Right. Oh, my gosh. Less activity for the cat to deal with.
猫当时已经是一副“我在哪？这到底是怎么回事”的状态了。好吧。所以有很多事情汇聚在一起才促成了这一幕。我要和你们分享一些兰迪·科德雷和杰夫·布里茨和我分享的事情，然后我要分享我个人的记忆。所以我想在剧本里，关于猫是怎么进到天花板里有几个备选方案。杰夫·布里茨极力争取保留猫钻进天花板、然后从天花板另一个地方钻出来的那个时刻。
The cat was already like, where am I? What's going on? All right. So a lot of things went in to make this happen. And I'm going to share with you some stuff that Randy Cordray and Jeff Blitz shared with me, but then I'm going to tell you my personal memories. So I guess in the script, there were a few alts about how the cat got in the ceiling. Jeff Blitz fought really hard to have the moment where the cat goes up in the ceiling
是的。那是他极力争取的东西。不过他说要做到这一点，需要两只长相匹配的猫和两个藏在天花板里的驯导师，一个用来抓住班迪特一号，另一个通过不同的天花板面板放下班迪特二号。所以最初的想法是，你要去找双胞胎猫。双胞胎猫。
and then out a different part of the ceiling. Yes. That was the thing he fought for. He said to do this, though, it would involve a pair of matching cats and two trainers in the ceiling, one to catch bandit one and one to drop bandit two through a different ceiling panel. So the idea originally was that you would go on a search for twin cats. Twin cats.
长相完全一样的猫。是的。兰迪说，我们与加利福尼亚州西尔玛的一家优秀动物训练公司合作。他们的名字叫鲍勃·邓恩动物服务公司。我们这次特技以及更多集数的专属猫咪驯导师是丹妮斯·桑德斯。她太棒了。我爱丹妮斯。兰迪希望你们知道，我们不仅对片场人类的安全，对动物的安全也非常重视。
Identical looking cats. Yes. And Randy said that we worked with an excellent animal training company out of Silmar, California. Their name is Bob Dunn's Animal Services. And our specific cat trainer for this stunt and many more episodes was Denise Sanders. She was fantastic. I love Denise. And Randy would want you guys to know that we took the safety of not only the humans
好吧，那是兰迪。兰迪是个真正的动物爱好者，他为我们所有人，无论是毛毛宝贝还是真人，都据理力争。好吧，所以珍娜，我的记忆是，为了这个特技我们排练了两天。哇。是的。其中一天就像是初步走位，但第二天的感觉就像是，好吧，我们
on set, but also the animals took it very seriously. Well that was Randy. Randy is a real animal lover and he advocated for all of us, fur babies and real people. Okay. So Jenna, my memory is we had two rehearsal days for this stunt. Wow. Yeah. One was just like a preliminary blocking, but then the second one was like, okay, we
必须像正式拍摄那样进行排练。我们最大的一次排练，有我、杰夫·布里茨、兰迪·科德雷、格雷格·丹尼尔斯。我想一些编剧也在场。我想我们的剪辑师迪恩可能也在场，所有将要参与这个时刻的人，奥斯卡，天花板上的驯导师。这次排练其实有很多人。如果我漏掉了你们中的某些人，那现场的人比你想象的要多。我有一个叫卡蒂娜·沃特斯的替身演员，因为他们其实不想让我扔这只猫。
have to practice this as if we're doing it. And our biggest rehearsal, it was me, Jeff Blitz, Randy Cordray, Greg Daniels. I think some of the writers were there. I think Dean might have been there, our editor, everyone that was going to be involved in this moment, Oscar, the trainer up in the ceiling. There was a lot of people actually for this rehearsal. And if I miss some of you guys, there was more people than you would imagine. I had a stunt woman named Katina Waters because they actually didn't want me tossing the cat
我们必须像真正拍摄一样练习。而我们最大的彩排，有我、杰夫·布利茨、兰迪·科德雷、格雷格·丹尼尔斯。我想一些编剧也在场。我觉得迪恩可能也在，我们的剪辑师，所有将要参与这个时刻的人，奥斯卡，天花板上的教练。其实这次彩排有很多人。如果我漏掉了你们中的某些人，现场的人比你们想象的还要多。我有一个名叫卡蒂娜·沃特斯的特技替身，因为他们实际上不想让我扔猫。
up in the ceiling, right? They wanted a professional animal wrangler stunt person. Yeah. Because what if- That makes sense. Right? What if I got it wrong? Right.
在天花板上，对吧？他们想要一个专业的动物驯兽师特技替身。对。因为万一——这说得通。对吧？万一我搞砸了呢？没错。
I'm not a professional animal wrangler stunt person. You're not a professional animal thrower? I am not. But as we started blocking the moments of the scene, the cat wrangler Denise was like, you guys, we can't toss a cat up in the ceiling. You know, we can't toss it up. We can't toss it out. There is no tossing of cats, guys, because not that it will harm the cat.
我可不是什么专业的动物驯兽师特技替身。你不是专业的动物抛掷师？我不是。但当我们开始排练这场戏的时机时，猫咪驯兽师丹妮丝就说，各位，我们不能把猫往天花板上扔。你知道的，我们不能把它往上扔。我们不能把它扔出去。不能扔猫，各位，倒不是说这会伤害到猫。
This isn't a very high distance or anything like that. It won't physically harm them. It won't physically harm the cat. And then she used this phrase, Jenna, that was like a scratch on the record player. She said, because it will blow out the cat. And this is clearly a cat wrangler term. It will blow out the cat. We all, all of us went, huh, blow out the cat.
这距离又不是很高什么的。这不会对它们造成身体伤害。这不会对猫造成身体伤害。然后她用了这样一个词，珍娜，听起来就像黑胶唱片被划了一下。她说，因为这会“毁掉”这只猫。这显然是猫咪驯兽师的专业术语。“毁掉这猫”。我们所有人都“啊？”了一声，“毁掉这猫”是什么意思。
And then Greg goes, because Greg's such an inquisitive minded person. He's like, I'm sorry, what does that mean to blow out the cat? Yeah. And she said, it will ruin its career. Now is that because just the stress of performing that stunt would make it so that the cat wouldn't be able to maybe go to work again? Like the cat would be okay physically, but it would be stressful. And they couldn't be sure that it would be a trainable cat in the future.
然后格雷格就问了，因为格雷格是个很有求知欲的人。他说：“不好意思，‘毁掉这猫’是什么意思？”对。然后她说：“这会毁了它的职业生涯。”那么，这究竟是因为表演这个特技的压力会让这只猫以后可能无法再去工作了呢？就像这猫身体上会没事，但这会很有压力。而且他们无法确定它以后还能不能成为一只可以被训练的猫。
Right. That's what I'm hearing. Yeah. That's exactly what we all heard. A cat will physically be fine, but you might make it so it's afraid and we won't be able to train it. Got it. Right.
对。我听到的就是这样。对。这确实是我们大家听到的。猫在身体上会没事，但你可能会把它吓坏，我们就没法训练它了。明白了。没错。
Okay. Right. So it could live out its life as someone's pet, but it's not going to be a working cat anymore. Not a stunt cat anymore. Okay. But this is her job, right? Like this cat working.
好吧。对。所以它可以作为某人的宠物度过余生，但它再也不是工作猫了。不再是特技猫了。好吧。但这是她的工作，对吧？比如这只猫在工作。
This is her livelihood. Right. And so Greg, like as a problem solver, he was like, well, what would it cost to retire the cat? Could we pay you and retire the cat? And that way you don't lose your income in this cat. Uh-huh. She didn't want to retire the cat.
这是她的生计。没错。所以格雷格作为一个解决问题的人，他就说，那让这猫退休要花多少钱？我们能不能付钱让你把这猫退休？这样你就不会失去这只猫带给你的收入了。嗯哼。她不想让这猫退休。
This is a very high earning cat. This is a very good cat. It's the largest cat they have. It's the largest stunt cat. Clearly the largest physically and the largest monetary stunt cat. So they came up with this idea. They made it work. This is what the animal trainer said that they could do.
这是一只收入极高的猫。这是一只非常优秀的猫。这是他们体型最大的猫。这是体型最大的特技猫。显然无论是身体体型还是带来的商业价值，它都是最大的特技猫。所以他们想出了这个主意。他们让它可行了。动物驯兽师说他们可以这么做。
We would toss up into the ceiling a fake cat. Okay. Okay. Yes. And then up in the rafters of the ceiling would be a trainer that would then gently be holding a real cat and release it onto my desk, which was just a few feet below. Okay. I think I got it.
我们会把一只假猫扔到天花板上。好吧。好吧。是的。然后天花板的椽子上面会有一个驯兽师，然后会轻轻抱着一只真猫，把它放到我的桌子上，桌子就在几英尺下方。好吧。我想我明白了。
Tossing cat up, blows out cat. Tossing cat up, blows out cat. Can't throw a cat. Dropping cat onto its feet. Totally fine. Just a few feet. Totally fine. You know what I have to say?
扔真猫，毁了猫。扔真猫，毁了猫。不能扔猫。把猫放到它的脚上。完全没问题。就几英尺。完全没问题。你知道我要说什么吗？
Sunny cat actually enjoys a good toss. I'm doing laundry on the bed and he'll come up and he likes it when I give him a big hoist onto the pile of laundry. And then he'll jump down and I'll do it again. Sunny, you could have been banned. Sunny could have been banned. He's like, I'll do it. I'll do the toss.
桑尼其实挺喜欢被好好抛一下的。我在床上叠衣服时，它会走过来，当我对它说“来个大飞跃”把它抱到一堆衣服上时，它可喜欢了。然后它会跳下来，我再来一次。桑尼，你本可以被禁赛的。桑尼本可以被禁赛的。它就像是，我来吧。我来做这个抛掷动作。
Yes. Sunny should have been banned it. Well, here's the deal. Randy even went to extra measures to make sure the cat would be fine when they were going to drop it on my desk. He and the animal trainers and our stunt guy, Eric Solke, they came up with this huge inflatable safety airbag that would decelerate and gently catch the falling cat. It was described as like falling into feathers and we did some practice runs and the trainers
是的。桑尼本该被禁赛的。好吧，事情是这样的。兰迪甚至采取了额外措施，确保猫在被扔到我桌子上时会安然无恙。他和动物驯兽师以及我们的特技演员埃里克·索尔克，他们想出了一个巨大的充气安全气囊，可以减速并轻轻接住下落的猫。这被形容为像掉进羽毛堆里一样，我们做了一些排练，驯兽师
signed off on it. It was fine. The cat wasn't traumatized at all. They hid this airbag in the corner of my accounting desk with like papers and stuff. But there was a cat airbag on my desk, okay, and the ceiling panel had breakaway foam rubber, all right. So it was all very cushy cushy. But now...
批准了。这没问题。猫一点也没有受到创伤。他们把这个气囊藏在我的会计桌角落里，用文件之类的东西盖着。但是我的桌子上有一个猫咪气囊，好吗，天花板上的嵌板是易碎的泡沫橡胶，好吧。所以一切都非常软绵绵的。但现在……
I just want to say they did all of this and then gave rain a real blowtorch. I know. They had an inflatable airbag cushion for this enormous cat. But now Jenna, enter in the people that make fake animals. I'm scared. I found them fascinating. So like, you know, if you have a show like CSI and there's a dead body, these are your people.
我只想说，他们做了这一切，然后给了雷恩一个真正的喷火器。我知道。他们为这只巨大的猫准备了一个充气气囊垫。但现在，珍娜，制作假动物的人登场了。我好怕。我觉得他们太迷人了。所以，你知道的，如果你有一个像《犯罪现场调查》（CSI）这样的节目，里面有一具尸体，这些就是你们要找的人。
They make fake humans. They make fake animals. Jenna, they had to meticulously match the exact cat that we were tossing in the ceiling. And it was a rush job. Randy said this fake cat cost $12,000. Oh my God! I know. And I want you to know that thing was one of the scariest things I've ever seen, held
他们制作假人。他们制作假动物。珍娜，他们必须一丝不苟地制作出一只与我们在天花板上抛掷的猫一模一样的假猫。而且这是一个紧急任务。兰迪说这只假猫花了我1万2千美元。噢天哪！我知道。而且我想让你们知道，那东西是我见过的、抱过的或摸过的最可怕的东西之一。
or touched. First of all, it had these yellow eyes that would just look at you. And then the fur felt real. But when you picked it up, it was gelatinous. So it was like flop. Like as you held it. Oh my God. Like imagine like flopping a towel over your arm, a big thick towel.
首先，它有着那种会直勾勾盯着你看的黄眼睛。然后毛摸起来感觉是真的。但当你把它捡起来时，它是胶状的。所以它就像是软塌塌的。就像你抱着它的时候。噢天哪。就像想象一下把一条毛巾搭在你的手臂上，一条又厚又重的毛巾。
It was like smooshy. It was frightening. I... We started kind of pranking with it. Like I said it on Oscar's desk and he walked up and he was like, oh God! I had to like start covering its face with a piece of paper because the thing was so creepy to look at. Where is it now?
它就像是软糊糊的。太吓人了。我……我们开始拿它开玩笑了。比如我把它放在奥斯卡的桌子上，他走过来，然后他就说：哦天哪！我不得不开始用一张纸盖住它的脸，因为这东西看起来太诡异了。它现在在哪里？
I don't know. It hasn't. NBC owns it somewhere, right? They paid for it. By the way, this is just the cat stuff. We haven't even gotten to the fact that Oscar has a whole bit he has to do. Oh yeah. Right?
我不知道。它还没……全国广播公司（NBC）把它藏在某个地方了吧？他们花钱买的。顺便说一句，这还只是猫的部分。我们甚至还没说到奥斯卡有一大段他必须完成的戏份。噢，是的。对吧？
So when we actually got to the day to shoot the stunt, I go over to the drawer, I pull out the cat. Now they said my dialogue and everything, I still had to be yelling, okay? So I open the drawer and you'll hear in the take, I say to the cat, it's okay. Like I'm trying to like be like, I'm not a bad person. I lift up this enormous cat and then I have to go to my spot where Oscar's going in the roof and they wanted so they could do that swishy cut. They wanted me to take the cat.
所以当我们真正到了拍摄特技的那天，我走到抽屉前，把猫拉出来。现在他们说我的台词还有一切，我仍然得大喊大叫，好吗？所以我打开抽屉，你会从镜头里听到，我对猫说，没关系。就像我试图表现得像，我不是个坏人。我抱起这只巨大的猫，然后我必须走到奥斯卡在屋顶上的那个位置，他们希望为了能做一个丝滑的转切。他们想让我拿着猫。
I'm holding it to my chest. They wanted me to swing the cat back behind me and then swing it up over my head and stop. This is the real cat. The real cat. Okay. The real cat gets the swinging motion. Swinging okay. Swinging okay.
我把它抱在胸前。他们想让我把猫甩到我身后，然后把它甩过我的头顶并停住。这是真猫。真猫。好吧。真猫要做出甩动的动作。甩动可以。甩动可以。
Swinging approved. Swinging approved. While I'm yelling, I only weighed 82 pounds. Right? I'm sure the cat loved that. You know what cats love? Screaming. And swinging.
甩动获批。甩动获批。当我大喊大叫时，我只有82磅重。对吧？我相信猫很喜欢那样。你知道猫最喜欢什么吗？尖叫。还有甩动。
Yeah. This cat probably weighed 20 pounds. I'm not exaggerating at all. It was enormous. Just the swinging and getting it to my stopping point. I was like, oh, God, and then I stop and I hold it in the air, freeze. Then they yell cut and in comes my stunt woman in the same outfit. She takes real cat.
是的。这只猫可能重达20磅。我一点也没夸张。它太巨大了。光是甩动并把它停在指定位置，我就想，哦，天哪，然后我停下来把它举在空中，定格。然后他们大喊咔嚓（Cut），我的女特技替身穿着同样的衣服上场了。她接住了真猫。
She holds it in the air. I step away because what she's going to do with the cat, Jenna, is kind of do the second motion where it appears like she's tossing, but she doesn't toss the cat. Okay. But she kind of gives it a little air, but not a lot of air. And this was like, they don't want you to get all scratched up. She knows how to give like a little thing. Yeah.
她把它举在空中。我退后一步，因为她要对猫做的事，珍娜，有点像是做第二个动作，看起来像是她在抛，但她并没有把猫抛出去。好吧。但她有点给它一点向上的空间，但不多。这就像是，他们不想让你被抓伤。她知道怎么给那么一小下。对。
They had to give the idea of the motion. Yeah. Right? Right. More than my swing. Got it. Okay. And then of course we had to get a take where I had to take Fakie Cat and do the same motion
他们必须营造出那个动作的意感。对。对吧？没错。比我的甩动还要多。明白了。好吧。然后当然，我们必须拍一个镜头，我必须拿着假猫，做出和女特技替身
as the stunt woman. I had to watch her and toss Fakie Cat in the ceiling. Right? Yes. They pieced all of that together. So Jenna, I had talked to Jeff Blitz about this moment a while back because I distinctly remember when we filmed it, two cats coming out of the ceiling instead of one. How, how, how, how did two cats come out?
一样的动作。我得看着她，把假猫扔进天花板。对吧？是的。他们把所有这些拼凑在了一起。所以珍娜，我前段时间和杰夫·布利茨（Jeff Blitz）谈过这个时刻，因为我清楚地记得我们拍摄时，天花板里掉下来两只猫，而不是一只。怎么，怎么，怎么，怎么会掉下来两只猫？
That's my memory. And I was like, wait, am I crazy? And I talked to Dean Holland who edited and I was like, Dean, did you have to CGI out one cat? Cause I know two cats came down. I remember seeing two cats. He was like, no. And so I talked to Jeff Blitz and he goes, yes, Angela, two cats came down.
这是我的记忆。然后我就想，等等，是我疯了吗？我和负责剪辑的迪恩·霍兰（Dean Holland）聊过，我说：迪恩，你是不是得用CGI特效删掉一只猫？因为我知道有两只猫掉下来了。我记得我看到了两只猫。他说：没有。于是我和杰夫·布利茨聊了聊，他说：是的，安吉拉，确实掉下来了两只猫。
And I was like, what? He said on the take we used, the trainer that was supposed to catch the Fakie Cat missed. And so then on action, Fakie Cat came out the other side and real cat. Oh, my gosh, two cats hit the desk and Jeff said, luckily the way the camera was positioned, it only caught one cat. And I think it's the real cat when you watch because it looks like a real cat comes out. Cause it hits and it kind of runs off, whereas Fakie Cat just would have gone plop. Yes.
然后我就想，什么？他说在我们用的那个镜头里，本该接住假猫的驯兽师没接住。所以当导演喊“开始”时，假猫从另一边出来了，真猫……哦，天哪，两只猫砸在了桌子上。杰夫说，幸好摄像机的位置摆得好，只拍到了一只猫。我觉得当你看到它时那是真猫，因为看起来像是一只真猫出来了。因为它砸下来然后跑开了，而假猫只会“啪嗒”一声掉在地上。是的。
Right? Yes. So there you go. One cat went up, two cats came down, but we got the shot. It took all those people and all that maneuvering, but it made it in the episode. Angela, that is amazing. I did not know all the details of that story. I was on the edge of my seat.
对吧？是的。所以就是这样。一只猫上去了，两只猫下来了，但我们拍到了这个镜头。这动用了所有人所有的周旋，但它确实剪进正片了。安吉拉，这太神奇了。我不知道那个故事的所有细节。我当时听得心都提到嗓子眼了。
I absolutely loved that. You guys, the crazy thing is it took me that long to tell that story, but it happened in five seconds. Oh my God. When we actually filmed it, it was so quick. So it was like me, draw a cat, swing, step out someone, Fakie Cat, oh my God, two cats, react to one. Well, you mentioned that there was something else going on during all this, which was Oscar
我太喜欢这个了。各位，最疯狂的是，我花了这么长时间才讲完这个故事，但它在片中只发生了五秒钟。噢天哪。当我们真正拍摄时，它太快了。所以就像是我，拉出猫，甩动，某人走开，假猫，天哪，两只猫，对其中一只做出反应。好吧，你提到在这期间还有别的事情在发生，那就是奥斯卡
going in and out of the ceiling. Yes. That was a whole other ordeal. Fakie told us that that part of the stunt of getting Oscar up into the ceiling was the other most challenging part of the stunt because there was nothing to climb into in the way that our set was built, like the actual lightweight drop ceiling. It was suspended from cables. Yeah.
进进出出天花板。是的。那是另一场折腾。费基（Fakie）告诉我们，特技中让奥斯卡上到天花板的那部分是特技中另一个最具挑战性的部分，因为按照我们布景的建造方式，里面根本没有可以攀爬的地方，比如那个实际轻量化的吊顶。它是用缆绳悬挂的。对。
Very thin rigging wires. It was Fakie ceiling, guys, because our set was inside a humongous soundstage. Yeah. So actually above the Dunder Mifflin offices was just air. If you walked outside, you could look up and just see these wires holding Fakie ceiling. Yeah. So he said in the weeks prior to filming this, our production designer, Michael Gallenberg, and construction coordinator, Tim James, had to completely re-engineer the ceiling.
非常细的索具钢丝。那是假天花板，各位，因为我们的布景是在一个巨大的声音舞台里面。对。所以实际上邓德米夫林办公室的上方只有空气。如果你走到外面，你可以抬头看到这些支撑着假天花板的电线。对。所以他说在拍摄前的几周里，我们的美术指导迈克尔·盖伦伯格（Michael Gallenberg）和施工协调员蒂姆·詹姆斯（Tim James）不得不完全重新设计天花板。
They had to build rafters basically that we didn't have, right? Yeah. We had to be enough to support not just Oscar, but all of the stunt personnel. He said on the day there were two stunt coordinators, the animal people, Oscar, Oscar stunt double, and an NBC universal safety coordinator all up in the ceiling. Can you imagine that guy's day at work? I can't. Like, he's not normally with us.
他们基本上不得不建造我们原本没有的椽子，对吧？对。必须有足够的支撑力，不仅要支撑奥斯卡，还要支撑所有的特技人员。他说那天有两名特技协调员、动物人员、奥斯卡、奥斯卡的特技替身以及一名NBC环球的安全协调员都在天花板上。你能想象那家伙那天的工作日吗？我无法想象。比如，他平时不和我们在一起。
He's just up in our ceiling now. I can tell you that I had to look up into the ceiling and it looked crowded. I get why someone might have missed a cat as it flew up there. Well, we got a fan question from Alex M. Did Oscar really fall through the ceiling? Yes. Well, yes and no, right? We pulled it off using both Oscar and a stunt double, right, Ange? Yeah.
他现在就在我们的天花板上。我可以告诉你，我不得不抬头看天花板，那里看起来很拥挤。我明白了为什么当猫飞上去时会有人漏接。好吧，我们收到了来自亚历克斯·M（Alex M.）的粉丝提问。奥斯卡真的从天花板上掉下来了吗？是的。嗯，是的，也不全是，对吧？我们通过同时使用奥斯卡和特技替身来完成的，对吧，安吉？是的。
So I reached out to Oscar and I was like, Oscar, you got to tell us everything about the ceiling. I guess he gets asked this a lot and he sent in this audio clip. I had a stuntman. I had a Moroccan. He was, I think he was from Morocco. He was from Cirque Soleil. He was a little shorter than me and he was a stuntman and I think he was jumping out from the hole and doing wonderful tumbles when he hit the ground.
所以我联系了奥斯卡，我说：奥斯卡，你得把关于天花板的一切都告诉我们。我猜他经常被问到这个问题，他发来了这段音频剪辑。我有一个特技演员。我有一个摩洛哥人。他，我想他是摩洛哥人。他来自太阳马戏团（Cirque Soleli）。他比我稍微矮一点，他是个特技演员，我想他是从洞里跳出来，落地时做了精彩的翻滚。
I did half of it. He did the really hard part. It was a very funny scene, very complicated. I remember in one of the shots, I made Steve laugh because one of the ways that I was coming down from the roof, on one of them, they had a big, a bar up there and it lowered me slowly through the hole and that was a funny way to come down and when I made eye contact with Steve, just hanging there with a straight face, of course he laughed and then they figured out another way to bring me down, which was the leap down, but first I would just like
我做了一半。他做了非常难的那部分。这是一场非常有趣的戏，非常复杂。我记得在其中一个镜头里，我逗笑了史蒂夫，因为我从屋顶下来的方式之一，在其中一次拍摄中，他们在上面装了一根大横梁，慢慢地把我从洞里降下来，那是一种很有趣的下来方式，当我与史蒂夫有眼神交流时，就那样面无表情地挂着，当然他笑了，然后他们想出了另一种把我放下来的方式，那就是跳下来，但首先我会喜欢
one of the things we tried was just like being lowered down from the thing, which didn't make sense but was very funny. Do you remember that? I remember it. I do too. It was very weirdly matrix-y. It was and Oscar was slowly coming. Like very slowly.
我们尝试的事情之一就像是从那个东西上面慢慢降下来，这说不通但非常搞笑。你还记得吗？我记得。我也记得。这感觉太诡异了，就像《黑客帝国》一样。确实如此，而且奥斯卡慢慢地下来了。就像非常慢一样。
What was that Tom Cruise movie where he slowly lowered himself down? It was impossible. It was like that. Oscar was like slowly coming out of the ceiling. It looked crazy. And Oscar, of course, did not break because he never broke and all the rest of us were like, we can't possibly continue as if that's physically possible. And if Steve broke, you know it looked ridiculous.
汤姆·克鲁斯那部他慢慢把自己放下来的电影叫什么来着？是《碟中谍》。就像那个一样。奥斯卡就像是慢慢地从天花板上出来。看起来太疯狂了。而且奥斯卡当然没有笑场，因为他从来不笑场，而我们其他人都在想，我们绝不可能继续假装这在物理上是可能的。如果史蒂夫笑场了，你知道那看起来会有多荒谬。
Well, let me break it down for you for anyone who wants to follow along. At two minutes, 38 seconds, the real Oscar is standing on his desk and he pushes up the ceiling tile. At two minutes, 43 seconds for that beat of Oscar actually jumping up and pulling himself into the ceiling. That's his stunt double. You'll notice you don't see his face. His double's name was Aladin Namu and to pull this off, I guess Aladin had to wear a safety
好吧，让我为任何想跟着看的观众剖析一下。在2分38秒时，真正的奥斯卡站在他的桌子上，他推开了天花板瓷砖。在2分43秒时，为了奥斯卡实际跳起并把自己拉进天花板的那个节拍。那是他的特技替身。你会注意到你看不到他的脸。他的替身名叫阿拉丁·纳姆（Aladin Namu），为了完成这个动作，我猜阿拉丁必须在奥斯卡的戏服里面穿一个安全
harness underneath his Oscar wardrobe and it had this cable that went up through his harness to a pulley that was manned by two guys in the ceiling. And after he would jump, these guys would like hoist him up using this pulley. You gotta trust the guys in the ceiling, don't you? Then at two minutes, 48 seconds, we see the real Oscar again. He's up there in the scaffold looking down. He was also secured by a harness and a cable just to make sure. Finally, at three minutes, 33 seconds, Oscar appears to break through another ceiling panel
安全带，上面有一根电缆，穿过他的安全带连到一个滑轮上，由天花板上的两个人操控。在他跳跃之后，这些人会用这个滑轮把他吊上去。你得信任天花板上的人，对吧？然后在2分48秒时，我们再次看到了真正的他在天花板上。他在那上面的脚手架上向下看。为了安全起见，他也用安全带和电缆固定了。最后，在3分33秒时，奥斯卡似乎打破了厨房附近克里德桌子旁边的另一个天花板。
over by the kitchen near Creed's desk. That's his stunt double's legs kicking. His reaction was so hilarious to me, sorry, go on. But at four minutes, six seconds, that is when the stunt team dropped real Oscar onto the floor. So many beats of the scene, so many. We haven't even talked about Stanley's heart attack. Oh my gosh.
那是他的特技替身的腿在踢腾。他的反应对我来说太搞笑了，抱歉，你继续。但在4分06秒时，那是特技团队把真正的奥斯卡扔到地板上的时候。这场戏有这么多的节拍，太多了。我们甚至还没谈到斯坦利的心脏病发作。噢天哪。
At the end of all of this, he's on the ground and Michael is like telling him he can't die. He can't die. He's shoving a wallet in his mouth. Yeah, Michael's yelling Barack Obama's president. You can't die, Stanley. We got a fan question from Megan G. Leslie David Baker spoke at my college and said that the scene where Michael puts the wallet in his mouth was improvised. Is this true?
在这一切结束时，他倒在地上，迈克尔一直在对他说他不能死。他不能死。他把一个钱包塞进他嘴里。是的，迈克尔在大喊“奥巴马是总统”。你不能死，斯坦利。我们收到了来自梅根·G（Megan G.）的粉丝提问。莱斯利·大卫·贝克（Leslie David Baker）在我的大学里演讲时说，迈克尔把钱包塞进他嘴里的那场戏是即兴发挥的。这是真的吗？
Lady, I looked it up in the script, it is not there. It ended with him saying you can't die Barack Obama is president. That wallet bit was on the day. Oh my gosh. Well, I have a fan question that made me chuckle, Jenna. Emma N wrote in and said, Meredith has these kind of dirty question mark, brown boots she's carrying at around one minute, 49 seconds. And throughout some of the cold open, was there any deleted scene or explanation about
女士们，我在剧本里查过了，上面没有。它以他说“你不能死，奥巴马是总统”结束。那个钱包的梗是现场发挥的。噢天哪。好吧，我有一个让我咯咯发笑的粉丝提问，珍娜。艾玛·N（Emma N.）发信说，梅迪思在1分49秒左右带着某种脏兮兮的问号棕色靴子。在整个片头里，有没有任何关于
this? Oh. Well, Emma, you got me curious. I went to your time code. You are not wrong. I took a photo. Look, Jenna, I'll put it in stories. What is that?
这个的删减片段或解释？哦。好吧，艾玛，你勾起了我的好奇心。我去了你的时间码。你没说错。我拍了一张照片。看，珍娜，我会把它发到快拍里。那是什么？
I looked at this photo and I was like, Emma, I recognize these boots. I would bet money that those are Kate's Ugg boots that Wardrobe gave us to keep under our desk when we were so cold. They're not Meredith's boots. So I texted Kate. I said, Kate, in stress relief when Dwight almost burns down the building, did you grab your actual Ugg boots from under your desk? Fans are asking and I sent her the picture and she wrote back, I did.
我看了这张照片，然后我说，艾玛，我认得这些靴子。我敢打赌，那是服装部门给我们放在桌子底下以防我们太冷时穿的凯特的雪地靴。它们不是梅迪思的靴子。所以我给凯特发了短信。我说：凯特，在《压力缓解》里德怀特差点烧毁大楼时，你是不是从桌子底下抓了你真正的雪地靴？粉丝们在问，我把照片发给她了，她回信说：是的，我拿了。
So the direction we were given was clearly everyone's panicking and they're grabbing their things. They want to get out of the building and she said, I grabbed my Ugg boots. They are actually not dirty. They're a dusty pink. Oh. So there you go, Emma. Nice catch.
所以我们接到的指令显然是每个人都在恐慌，他们在抓自己的东西。他们想离开大楼，她说：我抓了我的雪地靴。它们其实不脏。它们是那种尘土般的粉红色。哦。所以就是这样，艾玛。好眼力。
Lady, I think we should take a break. That's the cold open. That's just the cold open. We still have this whole episode to break down and there is so much more to talk about. All right. We'll be back. All right. We are back.
女士们，我觉得我们该休息一下了。那是片头。那仅仅是片头。我们还有整整一集要剖析，还有太多事情要谈。好的。我们马上回来。好的。我们回来了。
Dwight and Michael are at a meeting in corporate because, hi, Dwight almost burned the building down and Stanley had a heart attack. So they're having to meet with David Wallace and Kendall from HR. Yes. Kendall. Guest star alert. Kendall was played by John Hartman. Now we've heard of Kendall before.
德怀特和迈克尔正在公司开会，因为，嗨，德怀特差点烧毁大楼，而斯坦利心脏病发作了。所以他们不得不与大卫·华莱士（David Wallace）和来自人力资源的肯德尔（Kendall）开会。是的。肯德尔。客串明星警报。肯德尔由约翰·哈特曼（John Hartman）扮演。现在我们以前听说过肯德尔。
He was mentioned in previous episodes and we heard his voice, remember, when he yelled at Holly. Oh, yeah. So John Hartman did the voice and now here he is. He's at the table. He was so good. You know that bit where they do the little runner where like take heed. He did.
他在之前的剧集中被提及过，我们还听过他的声音，还记得吗，当他冲着霍莉大喊的时候。哦，是的。所以约翰·哈特曼配了音，现在他来了。他坐在桌子旁。他太棒了。你知道他们玩那个连击小梗的桥段吗，比如“听好了”。他做了。
Did you look it up to see if it was scripted? I did because Sonya Y wanted to know. And so did I. It was scripted. It was scripted until the very last Michael heeded again. Yes. They kind of added to the bit. Steve added to the bit at the very end, but everything else is scripted.
你查过这是否是剧本里写好的吗？我查过，因为索尼亚·Y（Sonia Y.）想知道。我也想知道。是剧本里写的。剧本里写了，直到迈克尔最后一次说“听好了”。是的。他们有点即兴添加了这个梗。史蒂夫在最后添加了这个梗，但其他一切都是剧本写好的。
I actually texted that couplet of dialogue to Paul Lieberstein and I said, this is perfection. You are so funny. And then Steve at the very end added one more and I can see Rain trying not to break. He actually has to look down at the table. Yeah. And there's two things I have to point out also in this scene. First of all, in this dialogue, Dwight's like, imagine my frustration, a safety officer that they're not listening.
我其实把那两句台词发给了保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein），我说：这简直完美。你们太搞笑了。然后史蒂夫在最后又加了一句，我能看到雷恩在努力憋笑。他实际上不得不低头看着桌子。是的。在这场戏里我还有两点必须指出。首先，在这段台词中，德怀特说：想象一下我的沮丧，作为一个安全官他们却不听指挥。
Excuse me, Angela Martin was the safety officer in basketball. She couldn't find the first aid kit because Dwight had moved it and she said, how many times do I have to tell you I'm the safety officer? It was like their first little like spat. So I don't know what's happened. Dwight clearly has not let this go and he thinks he's the safety officer. Well, he's not the safety officer anymore. No, he's not because Michael's going to be the safety man.
对不起，安吉拉·马丁在《篮球赛》里就是安全官。她找不到急救箱，因为德怀特把它移走了，她说：我还要说多少遍我是安全官？这就像是他们的第一次小摩擦。所以我不知道发生了什么。德怀特显然还没放下这件事，他认为自己是安全官。好吧，他已经不是安全官了。不，他不是了，因为迈克尔要当安全员了。
That's what he calls it. He calls it the safety man. I have one other thing I have to point out because it made me laugh so hard, Jenna. I rewound this and watch this beat three times when Michael gets up and walks out and looks out at the city, you know, and then he comes and sits down next to Kendall. He like scooches Kendall over and he says, can you shove it down, please? Shove it down, please. I didn't catch that.
他是这么叫的。他把自己叫作安全员。我还有一件事必须指出来，因为它让我笑得太厉害了，珍娜。我把这一段倒回去看了三遍，当迈克尔起身走出去看着城市风景，你知道的，然后他过来坐在肯德尔旁边。他把肯德尔挤到一边去，然后他说：请把它塞进去，好吗？请把它塞进去，好吗？我没注意到那个。
It's so funny. That is not in the script. Shove it down, please. It's not in the script. And the way that John and Andy Buckley just rolled with all of those little moments, oh, they're so good. Well, when they get back to Dunder Mifflin, Stanley is coming back into the office. Michael's like, shh, quiet, quiet, quiet.
太搞笑了。那不在剧本里。“请把它塞进去，好吗？”不在剧本里。而且约翰和安迪·巴克利（Andy Buckley）顺着所有这些小细节即兴发挥的方式，哦，他们太棒了。好吧，当他们回到邓德米夫林时，斯坦利正回到办公室。迈克尔就像是：嘘，安静，安静，安静。
No loud noises. Yeah. No surprises. Yeah. Stanley has a talking head where he explains that in the past he has been very abrupt with people, but the doctor said he needs to find a more positive way to relate to people or he will die. Mm-hmm.
没有大动静。是的。没有惊喜。是的。斯坦利有一个采访镜头，他解释说过去他对人一直很生硬，但医生说他需要找到一种更积极的方式与人交往，否则他会死。嗯哼。
Well, you notice in that talking head there was a montage, a montage of moments of Stanley being abrupt with people. Yeah, of him losing his cool. A montage like this was very unusual for our show. It was added to help give more context to the character of Stanley for all of those post-Superbowl viewers. I was going to say, because a documentary doesn't do a montage. Not normally.
好吧，你注意到在那个采访镜头里有一个蒙太奇，一个斯坦利对人态度生硬的时刻的蒙太奇。是的，他情绪失控的蒙太奇。像这样的蒙太奇对于我们的节目来说是非常不寻常的。它的加入是为了帮助为所有那些超级碗（Super Bowl）之后的观众提供更多关于斯坦利这个角色的背景信息。我正要说，因为纪录片是不会做蒙太奇的。通常不会。
Not normally. But when you're after the Superbowl, you do. Another beat of the scene that didn't make it in, it's in the deleted scenes that really made me laugh, Jenna, is that Michael wants everyone to help Stanley. He's urging them. So here is how that manifests. Stanley makes Stanley a mixed CD of Inya songs. Oh.
通常不会。但当你在超级碗之后播出时，你就会做。这场戏中没有被剪进正片、但在删减片段中让我大笑的另一个情节，珍娜，是迈克尔想让每个人都帮助斯坦利。他在敦促他们。所以它是这样体现出来的。斯坦利收到了一张印雅（Inya）歌曲的混合CD。哦。
Stanley's like, thanks. Michael assigns Kevin to be his bathroom buddy, as Kevin says, in case you have a heart attack on the crapper. Okay. And Stanley's like, I can go to the bathroom by myself. Thank you. Phyllis just looks at him and can't stop smiling. And she has a really sweet talking head where she says she's known Stanley Hudson a long
斯坦利说：谢谢。迈克尔指派凯文做他的“厕所搭档”，正如凯文所说，以防你在拉屎时心脏病发作。好吧。而斯坦利则说：我自己能去洗手间。谢谢。菲利斯只是看着他，笑得停不下来。她有一个非常温馨的采访镜头，她说她认识斯坦利·哈德森很长时间了，他的呼吸方式，那种大声的呼吸对她来说有一种抚慰作用。这真的很可爱。所以你有了那个菲利斯的高光时刻。然后迈克尔说：别担心，斯坦利，我给你弄了一个便携式除颤器。然后试图把它贴在每个人身上，大家都说：不，不，不，不，噢天哪，我记得我们当时拍那个场景。是的。然后迈克尔觉得这很好笑，想把每个人都连上去。
time and the way he breathes, his sort of loud breathing is soothing to her. It's really cute. So you have that Phyllis moment. And then Michael says, don't worry, Stanley, I got you a portable defibrillator. And then tries to go put it on him and everyone's like, no, no, no, no, no, oh my gosh, I remember shooting that. Yes. And then Michael like thinks it's funny and wants to like hook everyone up to it.
就像除颤一样。是的。那个词怎么说来着？给每个人除颤。然后凯文拿了除颤器，开玩笑地把它放在梅迪思的座位上。梅迪思坐上去甚至都没注意到，但她所有的头发都竖了起来。那是我们不得不做的另一个特技。他们不得不让凯特·弗兰纳里（Kate Flannery）的头发因静电竖起来。
Like defibrillate. Yes. How do you say that? Defibrillate everybody. And then Kevin gets the defibrillator and as a joke puts it on Meredith's seat. Meredith sits on it and doesn't even notice it, but all of her hair goes up in the air. And that's another stunt we had to do. They had to make Kate Flannery's hair rise up with static.
哇。虽然没剪进正片，但挺搞笑的。迈克尔决心确保我们所有人都知道如果斯坦利再次心脏病发作该怎么做。他要求我们所有人都去会议室参加心肺复苏（CPR）课程。是的。一门他希望由自己来上的课，但显然你必须有一个真正的CPR培训师，否则你拿不到那个假人。
Wow. Didn't make it in, but it was pretty funny. Michael is determined to make sure that we all know what to do should Stanley ever have another heart attack. He's asked us all to come into the conference room for a CPR class. Yes. A class he wishes he was running, but apparently you have to have an actual CPR trainer or else you don't get the dummy.
是的。红十字会（Red Cross）不会把那个假人玩偶交给你，除非你有真正接受过培训的CPR教练。我们收到了一个粉丝提问。好的。来自斯蒂芬妮·H（Stephanie H.）。我太喜欢这个提问了。谁扮演了CPR教练罗斯，为什么她这么完美？她绝对太棒了。她的名字叫罗宾·林奇（Robin Lynch）。
Yeah. The Red Cross won't give you the dummy doll unless you have an actually trained CPR instructor. We got a fan question. Okay. From Stephanie H. I loved this question. Who played Rose the CPR instructor and why is she so perfect? She is absolutely amazing. Her name is Robin Lynch.
她是一位女演员。我曾以为她是一名CPR教练。我联系了艾莉森·琼斯（Alison Jones），她说她通过一次普通的海选找到了罗宾，罗宾绝对是他们在试镜该角色时看到的最好的人选。她把这个角色演得非常正经。她来这里教CPR。他的办公室乱作一团，而她只是试图按部就班地进行。我确实私信了她的Instagram。
She is an actress. I believed she was a CPR trainer. I reached out to Alison Jones and she said she found Robin through just a general casting call and that Robin was by far the best person that they saw for the role. She just plays it so perfectly straight. She's there to teach CPR. His office goes off the rails and she just tries to stay the course. I did slide into her DMs on Insta.
是的，罗宾。我们曾试图联系你，罗宾，我们想跟你聊聊。如果你看到我们的消息，请让我们知道。我们会在回看节目中和你聊聊。我们应该谈谈在这门CPR课程中出错的所有事情吗？有很多。有很多。
Yeah, Robin. We tried to get a hold of you. We wanted to chat with you, Robin. If you ever see our message, let us know. We'll chat you up in a revisited. Should we talk about all the things that go wrong in this CPR class? There are many. There are many.
首先，从凯文开始。凯文在20秒时就放弃了。他说：我宣布放弃。是的。这就像是，还有谁想轮流试一下，德怀特说他绝对不要。随着摄像机从德怀特身上拉开以展现整个房间，珍娜，在9分50秒时，我正在对镜头外的人耳语：不。你在说什么？
First of all, it starts with Kevin. Kevin gives out at 20 seconds. He's like, I'm calling it. Yeah. This is like, does anyone else want to turn and Dwight says absolutely he would not. And as the camera is pulling back away from Dwight to reveal the room, Jenna, at nine minutes, 50 seconds, I am whispering to someone off camera, no. What are you talking about?
你在说什么呢？我不是在看着罗斯。我在看着镜头外的人。我不知道我在和谁说话。等等，让我问你这个问题。什么？你是不是在对另一个镜头说“不”？我想是的，也许吧，但看起来真的很诡异。
What are you saying? I'm not looking at Rose. I'm looking at someone off camera. I don't know who I'm talking to. Wait, let me ask you this question. What? Do you be saying no to the other camera? I think so, maybe, but it looks really weird.
而且我把它拍下来了，我要给你看。我把它发在快拍里，但首先我要给我的闺蜜看。好的。准备好了吗？点击播放。我不会的。你看到那个女士了吗？你在干什么？
And I filmed it and I'm going to show it to you. And I'll put this in stories, but first I'm going to show my BFF guys. Okay. Ready? Hit play. I would not. Do you see that lady? What are you doing?
我不知道，但我非常明确地在说“不”。看，看我的脸。不，我想，我不知道这是否是你即兴发挥的，你是不是对着镜头做的。我觉得这是我对马特（Matt）的B机位即兴发挥的。是的。安吉拉在删减片段中有一个采访镜头，她说：我才不把嘴凑到那东西上去呢。谁知道谁的嘴亲过它。
I don't know, but I'm very pointedly saying no. And look, look at my face. No, I think, I don't know if that's an improv you're doing, if you're doing it to camera. I think it's an improv that I'm doing to Matt's own B camera. Yeah. Angela in deleted scenes had a talking head where she's like, I am not putting my mouth on that thing. Who knows whose mouth has been on it.
所以我猜我是根据那个采访镜头即兴发挥的，但如果你注意到了，它看起来非常随机。这真的是一个非常非常棒的细节，女士。好吧，斯坦利要试一试，因为出于某种原因，迈克尔认为斯坦利应该学会如何对自己进行心肺复苏。我们可能不会一直在那儿，对吧？然后，当然，延续迈克尔的一贯作风，他接管了会议，对吧？他现在要告诉他们如何做CPR了，对吧？
So I think I was sort of improvising off that talking head, but it looks really random if you catch it. It's a very, very good catch lady. Well, Stanley is going to give it a go because for some reason Michael thinks Stanley should learn how to resuscitate himself. We might not always be there, right? And then of course in true Michael fashion, he takes over the meeting, right? He's going to tell them how to do CPR now, right?
而他们做的方法全都不对。罗斯说：听着，各位，你们需要每分钟按压一百次。她建议他们随着比吉乐队（Bee Gees）的《Staying Alive》的旋律进行按压。起初迈克尔把这与《我会生存下来》（I Will Survive）混淆了。但后来罗斯开始唱《Staying Alive》，你知道的，呃，呃，呃，呃，Staying Alive，Staying Alive。然后安迪开始唱《Staying Alive》，凯莉开始跳舞，这变成了一场舞会。如果你想听的话，我其实有这段音频。
And they're doing it all wrong. Rose says, listen guys, you need a hundred beats per minute. And she suggests they pump to the tune of staying alive by the Bee Gees. At first Michael confuses this with, I will survive. But then Rose starts singing, staying alive, you know, uh, uh, uh, uh, staying alive, staying alive. Then Andy starts seeing staying alive, Kelly starts dancing, it turns into a dance party. I actually have the clip if you want to hear it.
我们听听吧。呃，呃，呃，呃，Staying Alive，Staying Alive，呃，呃，呃，Staying Alive，Staying Alive。你从我走路的姿态就能看出，我是个妇女之友，没时间闲聊。为爱担忧，女人温情，自打我出生起就饱受欺凌，没关系，没问题，你不能视而不见，我是一个男子汉，男子汉……Staying Alive。Staying Alive。
Let's hear it. Ah, ah, ah, ah, staying alive, staying alive, ah, ah, ah, staying alive, staying alive. You can't tell by the way I use my walk, I'm a woman's man, no time to talk. Worries in love, women warm, been kicked around since I was born, it's all right, it's okay, you can't look the other way, I'm a man on a man on a man on a man on a man on a man on a man. Staying alive. Staying alive.
我是说可怜的罗斯。我们收到了来自苏格兰的梅根·D（Megan D.）的粉丝提问。红十字会女士的那场戏里有什么是即兴发挥的吗，比如凯莉的舞蹈或安迪的歌唱？没有，各位。整段戏，所有的歌唱和舞蹈，全都是剧本写好的。我们几乎完全按照剧本完成了这场戏。写得太绝了。
I mean poor Rose. We had a fan question from Megan D in Scotland. Was any of the scene with the Red Cross lady improvised, such as Kelly's dancing or Andy's singing? No guys. This whole thing, all the singing and the dancing, it was all scripted. And we followed this scene pretty much as written. Brilliantly written.
我查出来是谁提出这个想法的了。哦，我知道，告诉大家。是珍·索拉达（Jen Solada）。是的。整个《Staying Alive》的心肺复苏这个点子就是她想出来的。她说她听说这是真的。她查阅并交叉核对过了。她说她又交叉核对了一遍
I found out who pitched this idea. Oh, I know, tell them. It is Jen Solada. Yes. This whole staying alive CPR idea came from her. She said that she had heard it was true. She looked it up and cross-checked it. She said she cross-checked it again
因为她不想在电视上播放，除非这是真的。然后她跟我分享说，在《办公室》之前，她曾在《家居改造》（Home Improvement）担任过编剧助理，当时编剧们做过一集，讲的是乔纳森·泰勒·托马斯（Jonathan Taylor Thomas）饰演的角色发现自己的喉咙上长了一个肿块。结果证明那是甲状腺问题
because she didn't want to put it on TV unless it was true. And then she shared with me that before the office, she had been a writer's assistant on home improvement and that the writers had done an episode where the Jonathan Taylor Thomas character found a lump on his throat. And it turned out that it was a thyroid issue
在那一集里，对吧？珍说她后来负责拆信件，他们收到了来自所有这些家庭的信件，信中说在看了那一集后，它帮助挽救了他们孩子的生命，因为他们的孩子们也长过甲状腺肿块，正因为那一集，他们才去检查了。
in the episode, right? And Jen said that she was later in charge of opening the mail and they got letters from all of these families that said after watching that episode, it helped save their children's lives because their children had had a thyroid lump and because of the episode, they got it checked out.
而且各位，自从这集《压力缓解》播出以来，人们已经多次使用这种CPR技术来拯救生命。确实如此。珍跟我们分享说，她听说过一个把女人从车里拉出来并伴随着《Staying Alive》的旋律做CPR的家伙，就是因为这一集。我查过了。这是真的。
And guys, since this stress relief episode aired, people have used this CPR technique to save lives. They have. Jen shared with us that she heard about a guy pulling a woman out of a car and doing CPR to the tune of staying alive because of this episode. I looked it up. It's true.
有很多文章。我从这篇开始。好的，在2019年1月，《滚石》杂志（Rolling Stone）刊登了这个故事。《办公室》中涉及急救技术的一段场景被认为帮助挽救了一条生命，当时一名亚利桑那州的男子在完全没有接受过CPR培训的情况下，成功让一名处于医疗紧急状态的女性恢复了心跳。有趣的是，他的名字叫克罗斯·斯科特（Cross Scott）。
There's many articles. I'm gonna start with this one. Okay, in January of 2019, Rolling Stones ran the story. A scene from the office that dealt with first aid technique is credited to helping save a life after an Arizona man, despite having no CPR training, managed to resuscitate a woman in medical distress. His name, interestingly enough, is Cross Scott.
哇！是的，他的姓是斯科特。所以他在一辆正顺着土路下滑的汽车方向盘后面发现了一名失去知觉的女性。哇。他砸碎了车窗，把她救了出来，然后引述他的话说：我这辈子从来没有为做CPR做过任何准备。
Whoa! Yeah, his last name is Scott. So he found an unconscious woman behind the wheel of her car that was rolling down a dirt road. Wow. He smashed the window, got her out, and then he's quoted as saying, I've never prepared myself for CPR in my life.
我根本不知道自己在做什么。谢天谢地，斯科特看过那集关于CPR培训的《办公室》，知道要按照《Staying Alive》的节奏进行胸外按压。他们联系了红十字会亚利桑那州南部地区执行董事考特尼·斯兰纳克（Courtney Slanaker），她告诉《每日星报》（The Daily Star），如果你不做CPR，
I had no idea what I was doing. Thankfully, Scott had seen the episode of the office that dealt with CPR training and knew to do chest compressions to the cadence of staying alive. They reached out to Courtney Slanaker, executive director of the Red Cross Southern Arizona chapter, and she told The Daily Star that if you don't do CPR,
受害者就会死亡。不要害怕采取行动。你做的任何事情都会帮助那个受害者，并有望防止死亡。并且考特尼证实，《Staying Alive》确实是胸外按压的正确节奏。哇。珍·索拉达，你猜对了。
the victim will die. Don't be afraid to act. Whatever you do will help that victim and hopefully prevent a death. And Courtney confirmed that staying alive is in fact the correct rhythm for chest compressions. Wow. Jen Salata, you got it right.
哇。有太多这样的例子了，各位，但就在最近，今年1月，《今日秀》（Today Show）分享了一个四岁小女孩在玩抓人游戏时晕倒的故事，她的父亲马特·乌伯（Matt Uber）找到了她并开始做胸外按压。同样，是伴随着《Staying Alive》的旋律。
Wow. There's so many guys, but just recently, in January of this year, the Today Show shared a story about a four-year-old girl who collapsed while playing tag and her dad, Matt Uber, found her and started chest compressions. Again, to the tune of staying alive.
他被引述说：当我试图考虑该怎么做CPR时，我的脑海里字面意义上浮现出了《办公室》的那集，他们在那里进行CPR培训，并随着《Staying Alive》的节拍进行按压。我的意思是，仅仅想象那位父亲在那个时刻的情景就让我哽咽了。我知道。
And he's quoted as saying, when I was trying to think about what to do about CPR, my mind literally went to that episode of the office where they are doing CPR training and doing the compressions to the beat of staying alive. I mean, that just got me choked up to imagine that father in that moment. I know.
然后他能做点什么，任何他能做的事。我知道。我知道，还有更多。我知道还有更多的故事，但这两个是我印象最深刻的。太神奇了。其中一件事，在读了这些故事之后，珍娜，
And then he had something, anything he could do. I know. I know, and there's more. I know there's more stories, but those two were two that stood out to me. Amazing. And one of the things that, after reading some of these stories, Jenna,
人们分享的是，了解心肺复苏有多么重要，我们所有人都应该学习心肺复苏。是的，我们有《Staying Alive》，所以你知道节拍，但我们所有人都应该学习我们的CPR安全知识，因为它真的能挽救生命。我知道当我们有了儿子，我们的第一个孩子时，我和李都参加了婴儿CPR培训。
that people share is that, how important knowing CPR is and that we should all learn CPR. Yes, we have the staying alive, so you know the beats, but that we should all learn our CPR safety because it really can save a life. I know that when we had our son, our first child, Lee and I both did an infant CPR training.
一样，一样。但我们应该做个复习。是的。好吧，对罗斯来说还没结束。她还没脱离险境。事情即将变得更加疯狂。是的。她宣布我们未能拯救
Same, same. But we should do a refresher. Yeah. Well, it's not over for Rose. She's not out of the woods yet. Things are about to get even crazier. Yeah. She announces that we failed to save the life
我们CPR假人的生命。德怀特建议下一步的行动应该是获取用于器官捐献的器官。然后他当然抓起绑在小腿上的巨大刀子。小腿，是的。他切开了假人的胸膛。是的。
of our CPR dummy. Dwight suggests that the next course of action would be to harvest the organs for organ donation. And then he, of course, grabs the giant knife that is strapped to his calf. Calf, yeah. And he hacks into the dummy's chest. Yeah.
然后我们全都吓坏了。是的，我们吓坏了，因为接着他切下了假人的脸，把它戴在自己的脸上。就像《沉默的羔羊》一样。是的。我们收到了一些关于这个的粉丝邮件。人们想知道这一集里用了多少个CPR假人。
And we all freak out. Yeah, we freak out because then he cuts off the dummy's face and puts it on his face. Like Silence of the Lambs. Yeah. We had some fan mail about it. People would like to know how many CPR dummies were used in this episode.
好吧，我问了兰迪。我非常确定。雷恩确实切进去了，因为我们看着他做的。兰迪说我们总共用了三个CPR人体模型。现在，过一会儿，大卫·华莱士会说它们每个要3500美元。但兰迪说那是有点夸张了。他说有些高端假人
Well, I asked Randy. I know for sure. Rain really did cut into it because we watched him do it. Randy said we used three CPR mannequins in total. Now, in a minute, David Wallace is going to say that they cost $3,500 each. But Randy said that was a little exaggerated. He said there are some top end dummies that
好吧，我问过兰迪了。我很确定。雨确实对拍摄有影响，因为我们亲眼看着他拍的。兰迪说我们总共用了三个心肺复苏模拟人。等一会儿，大卫·华莱士会说它们每个要3500美元。但兰迪说那是有点夸大了。他说有些高端的假人
come with very sophisticated features like articulating heads and heartbeat simulators. Those cost at the time around $1,000 each. But we used one that cost about $750 each. OK. But listen, Dwight is in trouble again. He has to go back to corporate. And he has to discuss his mutilation of the CPR dummy.
带有非常复杂的功能，比如可活动的头部和心跳模拟器。当时那些东西每个售价大约1,000美元。但我们用的那个大概是每个750美元。好吧。但是听着，德怀特又惹麻烦了。他得回总公司一趟。而且他得去讨论他毁坏心肺复苏模拟人的事。
I really can't believe the guy is still employed. I know. Now he has this huge task where he has to go make this very public apology to his coworkers. And they have to sign that they received his apology. Yes. That's going to be now Dwight's task. Meanwhile, we've got this very interesting,
我真不敢相信这家伙居然还在上班。我知道。现在他有个巨大的任务，就是得去向同事们当众道歉。并且他们得签字确认自己收到了他的道歉。对。这下成了德怀特任务了。与此同时，我们还有一个非常有趣、
somewhat odd, other storyline that's going to come up. It really seems like it comes out of nowhere. It's in the break room. Andy, I guess, is really good at pirating movies. So you can see them before they come out. And Jim and Pam are going to watch this movie with Andy on his laptop. Yes.
有点古怪的另一条故事线要登场。感觉它真的是凭空出现的。就在茶水间里。我猜安迪很擅长盗版电影。所以你能在电影上映前看到它们。吉姆和帕姆将和安迪一起在他的笔记本电脑上观看这部电影。对。
We got a lot of fan mail about this pirated movie scene. Hannah E, Abby S, and Beth S said, I am absolutely obsessed with the strange mini movie Andy watches with Jack Black and several other big names. How did this subplot come about? Does it rhyme with Schmooper Bowl? It does. It does.
我们收到了很多关于这个盗版电影片段的粉丝来信。汉娜·E、艾比·S和贝丝·S说，我简直对安迪和杰克·布莱克以及其他几位大牌明星一起观看的那部奇怪的小电影着迷不已。这个支线剧情是怎么来的？它押韵于“超级碗”（Schmooper Bowl）吗？是的。确实是的。
Remember when I said there was that extra scrutiny? Well, one of the things that the network was very insistent about was that this episode have big name guest stars. So they could flash it about. Yeah. Jack Black. Jessica Alba. Yes, there was a lot of comparison
还记得我说过有那种额外的审查吗？嗯，电视网非常坚持的一点是，这一集必须有大牌客串明星。这样他们就可以拿出去大肆宣传。对。杰克·布莱克。杰西卡·阿尔芭。是的，有很多对比
to when other shows had run after the Super Bowl, like Friends, who had featured big guest stars. But Greg and the rest of our writers were very against this. Especially against it was Allison Jones, our casting director. They all felt that to have like a big name guest star walk into the office pretending to play a character at a small paper company would just totally
将其与其他在超级碗之后播出的节目进行对比，比如《老友记》，该剧曾邀请过大牌客串明星。但格里格和我们的其他编剧非常反对这一点。我们的选角导演艾莉森·琼斯尤其反对。他们都觉得，让一个大牌客串明星走进办公室，假装在一家小型纸业公司扮演一个角色，会彻底
shatter the reality of the documentary premise of our show. We would get all these new eyes on the episode maybe. But the conceit of our show is that it's a documentary. That's right. You can't have Jack Black come in and pretend to be a salesman. Exactly. But you can years later have James Spader play
粉碎我们节目纪录片设定的真实性。也许我们能借此吸引所有人对这一集的新目光。但我们节目的核心理念是它是一部纪录片。没错。你不能让杰克·布莱克进来假装当销售员。没错。但你可以多年后让詹姆斯·斯派德饰演
Robert California. And have Idris Alba come in and all these other people. Timothy Oliphant and Kathy Bates. OK, but for now. For now, our integrity is intact, OK? And Greg came up with this idea, this fix, that would not infect the reality of the show. And that was where the idea for Pam, Jim, and Andy
罗伯特·加利福尼亚。然后让伊德里斯·艾尔巴进来，还有所有这些其他人。蒂莫西·奥利芬特和凯茜·贝茨.好吧，但目前来说。目前，我们的完整性保持完好，好吧？格里格想出了这个主意，这个权宜之计，既不会打破节目的真实性。那就是帕姆、吉姆和安迪
to watch this pirated movie. And I guess Terry Weinberg, who was one of our original executive producers, was now working as the executive vice president of NBC Entertainment. And Greg said that she was really instrumental in fighting like the kind of top brass at NBC to agree to this fix. They did.
去观看这部盗版电影的想法。我想特里·温伯格，我们最初的执行制片人之一，当时正在担任NBC娱乐公司的执行副总裁。格里格说她在与NBC的高层力争同意这个权宜之计方面发挥了关键作用。他们确实同意了。
Jack Black was the first person to commit. He was all in. He loved our show. Clarice Leachman. Amazing, by the way. Amazing. She heard a pitch on what the story would be. And she was like, yes, I am in.
杰克·布莱克是第一个答应的人。他全力以赴。他超级喜欢我们的节目。克劳丽丝·利奇曼。顺便说一句，太棒了。太棒了。她听了关于这个故事会是怎样的构思后，就说，行，算我一个。
And then finally, we got Jessica Alba. So the movie is called Mrs. Albert Hannity. And Jack Black is playing Sam. Clarice Leachman is playing Lily, AKA Nana. And Jessica Alba plays Sophie. It's sort of a romantic love triangle story. Yeah, Jack Black is dating or engaged to Jessica Alba's character, and she's introducing him to her grandmother.
然后最后，我们请到了杰西卡·阿尔芭。所以这部电影叫《阿尔芭·汉尼蒂夫人》，杰克·布莱克饰演萨姆。克劳丽丝·利奇曼饰演莉莉，也就是奶奶。杰西卡·阿尔芭饰演苏菲。这有点像是一个浪漫的三角恋故事。对，杰克·布莱克在和杰西卡·阿尔芭饰演的角色约会或订婚，她正把他介绍给她的外祖母。
And there's an instant connection. I mean, they go to shake hands, and music starts playing. There's some electricity there. Well, I want you to know there were some alt ideas for this parody movie, Jenna. And I went back to the table read draft, not the shooting draft, just to see what it said in the table read. In the table read draft, the movie
然后他们一见钟情。我是说，他们去握手，音乐就响起来了。其中有些来电的感觉。好吧，我想让你知道，关于这部恶搞电影，其实还有一些别的备选点子，珍娜。我回过头去看了台词围读剧本，不是拍摄剧本，只是为了看看台词围读时是怎么写的。在台词围读剧本里，这部电影
was going to be called Hang Glider Cop. What? And Jack Black would be a cop named Tanner. That's kind of a rogue cop. And he gets, as punishment, sent over to the Hang Gliding Division. OK. And now he's going to be a Hang Gliding cop.
本来打算叫《滑翔翼警察》。什么？而且杰克·布莱克会饰演一个叫坦纳的警察。那有点像是一个不守规矩的警察。然后作为惩罚，他被派到了滑翔翼部门。好吧。现在他要当一个滑翔翼警察了。
A wacky comedy. Like a cop comedy. OK. They didn't go with that one. Probably getting a Hang Glider was too much of a project. Gosh, I'd love to see that movie. Hang Glider Cop. Jack Black, are you listening?
一部滑稽喜剧。就像那种警察喜剧一样。好吧。他们没有采用那个。可能弄一个滑翔翼工程太浩大了。天哪，我很想看那部电影。《滑翔翼警察》。杰克·布莱克，你在听吗？
Mm-hmm. HG Division. We got more fan questions about this. Livian G, Norit F, and Maddie L said, did we get to meet Jack Black, Chloris Leachman, or Jessica Alba? No. We did not work the same day as they worked.
嗯哼。滑翔翼部门。我们收到了更多关于这个的粉丝提问。利维安·G、诺里特·F和麦迪·L问，我们有没有见到杰克·布莱克、克劳丽丝·利奇曼或杰西卡·阿尔芭？没有。我们工作的那天跟他们不是同一天。
They filmed all of their stuff in one day at a private residence in West LA. The rest of us all had the day off. They didn't even come to our base camp. No, they were at a house. I looked it up on the call sheet. They started really early that day. On the call sheet, it said breakfast
他们把所有的戏份都在一天之内在西洛杉矶的一处私人住宅拍完了。我们其他人那天都放假。他们甚至都没来我们的营地。没有，他们在一所房子里。我在通告单上查过。那天他们开始得很早。通告单上写着
would be ready for the crew at 4.42 AM in a nearby park. Oh, they had to get everything in one day. Yeah. The actors all arrived really early. They did their hair, makeup, and wardrobe fittings all in the morning. And then they were finally allowed to go into the neighborhood where the house was located
早晨4点42分在附近的一个公园为剧组准备早餐。哦，他们得把所有东西都在一天内拍完。对。演员们都到得很早。他们早上就做好了发型、妆容和服装试穿。然后他们终于被允许进入那栋房子所在的社区
at 7 AM. So they had vans that took everyone from this park base camp over to the location. And that's where they filmed it. So we never met. So while they're watching Mrs. Albert Hannity, we start seeing Pam getting all these text messages. And we learn this storyline that Pam's parents
是在早上7点。所以他们有面包车把所有人从这个公园大本营送到拍摄地点。这就是他们拍摄的地方。所以我们从没见过面。因此，当他们在看《阿尔芭·汉尼蒂夫人》时，我们开始看到帕姆收到所有这些短信。我们了解到剧情说帕姆的父母
are in a rough patch. Yes, and that Pam's dad is bunking with Jim and Pam. It is really funny, though, that Jim and Pam were having these little sidebar relationship conversations. And Andy thinks it's about the movie. Andy thinks you guys are just like geniuses at relationships. That you can just figure all this stuff out. Well, something else I should mention, Angela,
正处于一段艰难时期。是的，帕姆的爸爸和吉姆与帕姆挤在一起住。不过真的很搞笑，吉姆和帕姆当时在进行这些微小的旁支感情对话。而安迪以为那是关于电影的。安迪以为你们俩在处理感情问题方面简直是天才。觉得你们能把这些事情全搞清楚。好吧，我还要提一件事，安吉拉，
is that we were actually watching this movie. That's one of my questions for you. I was like, ask Jenna, were they actually watching the movie on the laptop? So we were. How could you not react to Klara's coming out of the tub? You had to be distracted on your phone. I was like, holy crap.
就是我们其实是在看这部电影。这是我要问你的问题之一。我当时想，问问珍娜，他们真的在笔记本电脑上看那部电影吗？我们确实在看。你怎么能不对克劳丽丝从浴缸里出来做出反应呢？你一定是被手机分心了。我当时想，天哪。
So they had shot this a long time ago. If you look at the call sheets for this episode, this bit of us in the conference room was not even on the schedule for these nine days. We shot this another week later so that they could put together this mini movie so that we could have some reactions. The first time they played them for us, we couldn't speak. We were riveted.
所以他们很久以前就拍了这个。如果你看这一集的通告单，我们在会议室里的这个片段甚至不在那九天的日程表上。我们又过了一周才拍这个，这样他们就能把这部微电影剪辑好，好让我们做出一些反应。他们第一次给我们放映时，我们说不出话来。我们全神贯注。
We were like, what are we watching? That was what I thought. I was like, how can Jim and Pam not just be falling out of their chairs right now? And Andy's like, guys, they're making out. So what they did was they showed it to us, and then we watched a blank screen, but we knew what we were supposed to be reacting to.
我们当时想，我们在看什么？我当时就是这么想的。我心想，吉姆和帕姆怎么现在还没从椅子上跌下来呢？而安迪却说，伙计们，他们在亲热呢。所以他们做的是，他们把它放给我们看，然后我们看着一个空白屏幕，但我们知道我们应该做出什么反应。
You knew the beats of it. Yes. And then they inserted it into the screen. If you notice, it's all over the shoulder onto the thing. I was very curious about that. Yeah, it was bunkers. Well, after all the texting with Pam's mom and dad, Pam says, Jim, can you talk to my dad?
你知道它的节奏。对。然后他们把它插到了屏幕上。如果你注意的话，全都是越肩镜头拍那个东西。我对那个非常好奇。对，太疯狂了。好吧，在和帕姆的爸爸妈妈发了无数短信之后，帕姆说，吉姆，你能跟我爸谈谈吗？
You're so good at talking to people. Yeah, maybe he'll open up to you. Yeah. This is not going to go the way Pam planned. Yeah. But that's for next week. Well, before we close out this episode, Michael has decided to do yoga in the conference room.
你那么擅长和人聊天。对啊，也许他会对你敞开心扉。对。这可不会按帕姆计划的那样发展。对。但那是下周的事了。好吧，在我们结束这一集之前，迈克尔决定在会议室里做瑜伽。
For relaxation. It did really make me laugh when he was like, oh, if you have your legs open, close them. No one needs to see that. Oh, or whatever he said. Correct me up. It also really made me laugh when Jim says to Pam, don't open your eyes.
为了放松。当他说，哦，如果你把腿张开，把它合上。没人需要看那个。哦，或者不管他说了什么，真的把我逗笑了。逗死我了。当吉姆对帕姆说，别睁开眼睛时，也真的把我逗笑了。
And she says, why? Oh, god. I don't know if you noticed Dwight and Angela are laying side by side. Oh. Yeah, that's because there was a deleted scene where Dwight whispers to her, I will make love to you the way I used to if you will sign my apology letter.
她问，为什么？哦，天哪。我不知道你有没有注意到德怀特和安吉拉并排躺着。哦。对，那是因为有一个被删掉的镜头，德怀特对她耳语说，如果你在我的道歉信上签字，我会像以前那样和你亲热。
And she's like, ah, no. Wow. Well, during all of this, Stanley has a little heart monitor on. And it beeps whenever he gets stressed. Turns out every time Michael gets close to him, it starts beeping. And then when Michael walks away, it stops.
而她的反应是，啊，不要。哇。好吧，在这一切发生的同时，斯坦利身上带着一个小型心率监测器。每当他感到压力时它就会发出哔哔声。事实证明，每当迈克尔靠近他时，它就开始哔哔叫。然后当迈克尔走开时，它就停了。
So Michael has this very funny talking head where he says it turns out that Dwight wasn't the killer. After all, the killer was Michael. And he says, quote, you never suspect you're the killer. It's a great twist. Great twist. Oh my gosh, you guys, that was stress relief part one. I know.
所以迈克尔有一个非常搞笑的采访镜头，他说原来德怀特不是凶手。毕竟，凶手是迈克尔。他说，引述一下，“你永远不会怀疑自己就是凶手。”这是一个很棒的转折。很棒的转折。天哪，伙计们，那是《缓解压力》的上集。我知道。
We did it. Next week is part two. Boom, roasted. That's next week. Thank you to everyone who contributed to this episode. Thank you, Oscar, Randall, Rain and Brian for sending in your audio clips. Guys, Rain and Brian both have podcasts.
我们做到了。下周是下集。轰，烤得好。那是下周的事。感谢所有为这一集做出贡献的人。感谢奥斯卡、兰德尔、雷恩和布莱恩发来你们的音频片段。伙计们，雷恩和布莱恩都有播客。
They are great. Rain is the host of Metaphysical Milkshake. And Brian is the host of the Office Deep Dive. Yes. And also a huge thank you to Randy Cordray, Greg Daniels, Jeff Blitz, Jen Salata, Paul Lieberstein, Dean Holland, James Carey. Oh my gosh, Kate Flannery.
它们太棒了。雷恩是《玄学奶昔》的主持人。布莱恩是《办公室深度探秘》的主持人。是的。还要非常感谢兰迪·科德雷、格里格·丹尼尔斯、杰夫·布利茨、珍·萨拉塔、保罗·利伯斯坦、迪恩·霍兰德、詹姆斯·凯里。哦，天哪，凯特·弗兰内里。
We reached out to so many people. We always say thank you, but it's because we mean it. Really? Yeah. Thank you. Thank you, guys, so much. And thank you for listening. We'll be back next week with part two.
我们联系了这么多的人。我们总是说谢谢，但那是因为我们是真心实意的。真的吗？对。谢谢。非常感谢你们，伙计们。也感谢你们的收听。我们下周带着下集回归。
Have a good one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico.
祝你们过得愉快。感谢收听“办公室辣妈”。“办公室辣妈”由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡茜·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code OFFICE. Tell your viewers on our channel. If you liked our show, comment bellow. Also comment below if you want to see a new video.
我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要想收听“办公室辣妈”的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。若想免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码OFFICE。在我们的频道上告诉您的观众。如果你喜欢我们的节目，请在下方评论。如果你想看新视频，也请在下方评论。
Otherwise, we'll talk about it. We'll be building it together. We'll do it inami. Thanks for watching. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
否则，我们会讨论它的。我们将一起构建它。我们会用意念来做这件事。感谢观看。这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。